HEARING. OBVIOUSLY COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION TO THE
PANDEMIC WE ARE CONTINUING TO
PUT TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE.
SOMETHING'S WRONG MY COMPUTER
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASK BEING WORN AND
EIGHTEEN BY ALL
PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE
IN THE ROOM OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY OF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON THE
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TO TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
HEARING ROOM. INCLUDING WOMEN
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. WE WILL ALSO BE USING
MODERATE OF PHONE TELEPHONE
SERVICE HROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AS WE HAVE. ONLY A
LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTS AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE EIGHT
AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
HELP I ALSO WANNA NOTE THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TO THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. NOW
I'D LIKE TO GO OVER A FEW
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE BILLS
BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WILL TAKE
NO MORE THAN TWO PRIOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR WITH CONCERNS. THESE WHAT IS
LOVE TOO MUCH MINUTES EACH TO
REVIVE THEIR TESTIMONY ALL
SUBSEQUENT. WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME. THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY FINALLY. IT IS
MY DESIRE TO PROVIDE ALL THOSE
WISHING TO REGISTER THEIR
POSITION ON A BILL THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO HOWEVER.
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS AND THE
NUMBER OF BILLS BEING PRESENTED
WE MAY NEED TO LIMIT THE
DURATION OF ME TO TESTIMONY.
WITH THAT. WE HAVE A QUORUM. IS
HIGHLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M HERE HERE. HERE. THERE HERE
I MEAN THERE GETTING HERE MAYES
HERE NAY MULLIN FEATURING OUR.
BURKE HERE WORK HERE RIVAS.
THERE ARE TWO YEAR THEY ARE.
MORE ABOUT. THANK YOU- I I'M
ELEVEN ALL RIGHT. AB AT WHICH
WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT AND
IMMEDIATE TAX RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC WE ARE ALL AWARE
OF THE DAMAGE THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON OUR COULD
COME A KANEMI AND WE ARE
GREATLY RELIEVED WHEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PASSED THE
CARERS ACT LAST YEAR AMONG.
OTHER THINGS THE CARE ACT
PROVIDED FORGIVABLE LOANS TO
THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
IN ADVANCE GRANTS UNDER THE
ECONOMIC INJURY DISASTER LOAN
PROGRAM. THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
PROVIDED INVALUABLE INFUSION OF
MONEY TO STRUGGLING BUSINESSES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. LAST YEAR IN
FURTHERANCE OF THE FEDERAL.
PROGRAM WE PASSED AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN TO ENSURE THAT
BUSINESSES WOULD NOT HAVE TO
PAY INCOME TAX UNFORGIVEN PPP
LOANS. IN LIGHT OF THE
CONTINUED ECONOMIC CONDITIONS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RECENTLY
PASSED THE CONSOLIDATED
APPROPRIATIONS ACT TO WRITE AN
ADDITIONAL ROUND OF FUNDING TO
SMALL BUSINESS. AB EIGHTY BUILT
UPON LAST YEAR AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY GIVING
STRUGGLING CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
EVEN MORE RELIEF. AB AT ENSURES
EVERY TAXPAYER DOES NOT HAVE TO
PAY TAXES ON ANY FORGIVEN PPP
LOAN IT ALSO ALLOWS TAXPAYERS
THAT SUFFERED AT LEAST A 25%
REDUCTION IN REVENUE. TO DEDUCT
ALL EXPENSES PAID FOR WITH FOR
GIVEN PPP LOANS AND LESS THEY
ARE PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES.
AB AT ALSO EXCLUDES FROM GROSS
INCOME FEDERAL ADVANCE. GRANTS
PROVIDED UNDER THE E. I D. L.
PROGRAM AND ALLOWS ALL
TAXPAYERS TO FULLY DEDUCT
EXPENSES PAID FOR WITH THESE
GRANTS E. I D. L. GRANTS ARE
TARGETED TO SMALL BUSINESSES
LOCATED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE SUFFERED
A LARGE DROP. IN SALES. AT A
TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
ARE STRUGGLING IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT THE STATE LEADERS DO
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER TO
HELP AB EIGHTY PROVIDES
CRITICAL TIMELY AND SIGNIFICANT
TAX RELIEF TO THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT. NEED IT MOST. I AM JIM
CHAMBERLAIN FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND STEVEN MCCARTY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MANAGER- I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES TESTIFYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT WITH THE MODERATE
PLEASE CONNECT. US FIRST WITH
MR J. J. CHAMBERLAIN OF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LINES OPEN. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
JAY CHAMP WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
MISTER OF AB EIGHTY AS IT WOULD
PROVIDE NEEDED TAX TO THE SMALL
THE THAT WERE HIT HARD BY THE
ECONOMIC. IMPACT OF THE COCONUT
PANDA. ALL I'M GOING THE BEACH
AS I THE CHAIRED IT DID A GREAT
JOB SIX WHAT THE BILL DOES.
CALM THAT WE ARE WE ARE IN. OF
THIS. AND I'M TO ANSWER ANY.
THANK YOU WHAT THE MY NOW
PLEASE CONNECT WOULD MISTER
STEVE. OF THE- ALTERS THIS OF
WITH ASSOCIATION. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND STEVE MCCARTY
RECORDS THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS. JERRY REPRESENTS ALL
pMERCHANDISE DEPARTMENT STORE.
RETAIL RESTAURANTS STREET
SPECIAL RETAIL. I'M OF THE
INDUSTRY AND THE SMALL
INDEPENDENT OWNED WHO WERE WHO
HARDEST BY THE STATE. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY WILL BURKE HER
AUTHOR OF BILL EIGHTY AS WELL
AS SEVENTY SO BY CO AUTHORS
FROM BOTH HOUSES. LAST YEAR
OVER TWELVE. RETAIL SO BECAUSE
NATIONWIDE. MANY OF WERE DOING
NON. DURING PEAK PEAK MONTHS OF
THE CAN DOWN. DOES THE SURVIVED
OFF EACH OTHER WAYS TO GET TO
SERVE WORK AND HE CONTENTS
THEIR- SOME TOOK OUT LOANS
BORROWED FAMILY OR RELY ON
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. IS AFLOAT NO
SIR WE WOULD SERVE SOON TO SOME
SENSE NORMALCY. PLEASE
BUSINESSES PPP. OFFERED ALL.
GIVING BILLS OWNERS ACCESS TO
LOOK. AND ENSURING THAT CONSUME
TO PAY THEIR- INTO THEIR DOORS
OPEN. HOWEVER FOR THE WHO ARE
HAVE THOSE LOANS FORGIVE UNDER
PRO- THE PROCESS OF ANOTHER SO
TAX CREATES NEW. IT'S VIED
IMPORTANT FOR ACT PROJECT THESE
BUSINESS ON THE BILL. OF THE
PEOPLE EMPLOY. CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY ONLY COME BORING
INSURED ARE SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE EVER TOOL TO THEM THE
PROGRAMMER FROM EXPIRY IN THE
PAST FOURTEEN. AB A CREATES
HOLCOMB FOR CALL BUSINESSES
MAXIMIZES THE POSITIVE THEY- OF
KEEPING PROGRAM. WE SHOULD TO
THIS ACT TO FOR LOANS TWO
MONTHS. TAX BY. ON BEHALF OF
THE RETAIL INDUSTRY ANALYST WE
WERE YOU SHOULD COMMISSION PORT
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WITH THE MODERN NOW PLEASE-
OPEN UP MAINLINE FOR ANY
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF
YOU TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF EIGHT
EIGHTY PLEASE ONE AND ZERO THIS
TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT SIX COMMENTING HERE WILL
GO TO ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE MATTER NOT LIKE
HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF WORLDWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CINDY HILLARY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SHE WAS THE-
NEXT. IS THERE ANY. ONE ALSO ON
THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
IS REALLY HARD TO WRITE. WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD AND LET ME
KNOW MODERATE VIEW THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE WE CAN COME BACK.
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION AT THIS TIME. NOW ADAM
JR THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND I SEE ONE.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS MY
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB AT. THANK YOU.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S ONE PRIME
WITNESS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WITH THE MODERATE
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH. ANTHONY
SAMPSON. FOR THE CALIFORNIA CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION. HI GOOD
MORNING AND SHARED MEMBERS AND-
WITH SAMSON ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION I JUST WANT TO START
BY APPRECIATING ALL THE HARD
WORK- THAT THE CHAIRS PUT INTO
THIS BILL LEADERSHIP IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I KNOW IT'S
GONE THROUGH A COUPLE OF
ITERATIONS- BUT UNFORTUNATELY
WE ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION
TODAY- SPECIFICALLY WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF NEW CAR DEALERSHIPS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE CONFORMITY CONTAINED
IN THE MEASURE. STATISTICALLY
AB EIGHTY UNTIL PENALIZES. THAT
OBTAINED EXPERTS ROUND HE P.
LOAN. USE THE FUNDSFOR.
PURPOSE NAMELY TO MAIN THEIR
ROLE DURING THE CODE NINETY
PANDA. BUT WHICH CAN DAM. THAT
FIVE WERE IN RECEIPTS SPEAKING.
CORE INTO NINETEEN AND TWENTY.
NEARLY ALL NEW CAR CAL YOU
DEALERS THAT EIGHTEEN OF G. P.
Y. OBTAINED FIRST ROUND ONES
WHICH THAT 5% WERE. REQUIREMENT
COULD NOT APPLY IT THAT TIME
FEDERAL. UNDERSTOOD THIS DOT HI
MORE STIR AND ALLEGED
REQUIREMENTS FOR SECTOR ROUND
ONE. BUT THE 20% BUT CONCEPT
THAT HAD NOT EVEN BEEN. HAD
THAT THEY TO HAD NOT BEEN
INJURED. AT THE TIME TO HELP
NEW CAR DEALERS ATTAIN PPO ONES.
SUFFER KALP TO NOW APPLY TWENTY
FIVE PER RATE. IN WRETCH ACTIVE
TO THE FIRST ROUND PP LINES CAL.
CAPS IS CAN. AND HARM THE VERY
BUSINESSES THAT YOU THE STOCK
TO RETURN THEIR CAL. WERE
DURING TIP TIME. WE ALSO DON'T
QUITE UNDER WHY HE BE EIGHTY
PER TAKES. ACTS WITH THE TYPE
OF. RATHER FULL CONFORMITY
APPROACH JUSTICE K. GENERAL
REVENUE ARE SO SIXTY POINTS
BILL. AHEAD OF WITH THE DIP OF
FINE EXPECTED THIS WOULD HAVE
MARK. LIKE SO MANY SO OF THE BE
SALE OPEN AND TO CATCH HIT
DURING EARLY MY OF TWO TWENTY.
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE SALES TWENTY
ONE POINT SEVEN IN. TWO MISTER
SAMPSON. MR- MMHM. HELLO
MODERATOR. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
THE TWO MEN TO- EIGHT POINT
NEARLY A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE STATEWIDE AND
LIKE SO MANY BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE WORKED
EXTREMELY HARD DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO RETAIN THEIR
WORKERS AND PAY THEM FAIRLY SO
THAT THEIR FAMILIES CAN
WITHSTAND THIS TIME OF ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY. INTERMEDIATE
THEREFORE AFTER IN CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE FULL CONFORMITY ACTION
FOR STATE INCOME TAX PURPOSES
SURE THE BUSINESSES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THEY WORK HARD TO
RETAIN AND PAY THEIR EMPLOYEES
DURING ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT ECONOMIC TIMES IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY ARE NOT
CAPS WITH THOSE EFFORTS I AGAIN
THANK THE CHAIR AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING OUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WHAT THE MODERATE PLEASE NOW
OPEN THE MAIN LIFE IN ADDITION
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH IN OPPOSITION OF AB
AT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OVER TO
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS ROBERT BRISKIN TAX
ATTORNEY I AM IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NUMBER EIGHTY WE
NEED TO PASS IMMEDIATELY ARE
THAT SIR TARLETON'S ANOTHER TAX
PREPARES CAN ENGAGE IN. SIR
WE'RE- WHERE THE FOR OPPOSITION.
SUPPORT HAS ALREADY. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE- THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION VIA REMOTE VIDEO.
STATION AT THIS TIME. AND I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WASHINGTON SUSPEND OPPOSITION
EITHER. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. MISTER
COURT- SO MY WITH THE THIS ARE
WOULD HAVE FULL FEDERAL
CONFORMITY HOWEVER THE DATE IS
LATE AND I KNOW THE CHAIR
WANTED THAT. HOWEVER WE ALSO
WANT TO BILL IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE VETOED AND- SO IT'S NOT IT
WAS NECESSARY TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL. WE HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. MISTER BASS YEAH
FIGHT CAN JUST ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- AND I LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES JUST SPOKE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TIME IS
LATE- AND- THIS NEEDED TO BEEN
DONE- NOT WEEKS AGO BUT MONTHS
AGO- I ACTUALLY DID PREPARE
TAXES FOR A LONG TIME. I
UNDERSTAND- THE HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS I NOT ONLY- IS IT- FOR
ACCOUNTS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
INFORMATION BUT IS ALSO
SOFTWARE- THAT HAS TO BE DONE
TO ALLOW FOR- IT COUNTS- TO BE
ABLE TO GO IN AND BE ABLE TO
DO. TO DO THE WORK AND I LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE HAD WISHED THAT
THIS THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN-
BEEN FULL CONFORMITY- THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A FULL FULL
FULL CONFORMITY- AND THE
REASON- THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
A FULL CONFORMITY IS THIS THE
BILL AS IT'S- AS IT'S CRAFTED.
I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME I
DON'T KNOW OF ANOTHER
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH I
CALIFORNIA HAS DECIDED TO TAX
FEDERAL GRANTS- I DON'T KNOW OF
IF THAT'S EVER HAPPENED BEFORE-
WHAT IS BEFORE US SAYS THAT IF
YOU'RE A SMALL BUSINESS AND YOU
RECEIVE THE PPP LOAN. AND THAT
LOAN WAS FORGIVEN THAT UNLESS
YOU HAD A 25% A RENDON MAKE
SURE THAT I'M WRONG I'M HERE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE FOR
CLARIFYING THAT UNLESS YOU HAD
A 25% REDUCTION. IN YOUR HEY
OVER OR YOU PAY YOUR GROSS
RECEIPTS OVER TWENTY TWENTY
NINETEEN THEN YOU ARE GOING TO
PAY TAXES FULL STATE TAXES IN
CALIFORNIA ON THAT NOTE ON THAT
FORGIVENESS OF THE PPP LOAN IF
YOU HAD MADE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS GROSS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND YOU HAD MADE. A
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND A GROSS
RECEIPTS IN TWENTY TWENTY YOU
ARE GOING TO PAY TAXES- ON-
THAT UP ON THAT INCOME AND I
THINK THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
FIRST. A IN CALIFORNIA THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AWFUL CAN- THE
MAIN THE ONE QUESTION I HAVE
AND- INSIDE A NEW CARL CARDIO.
SO LETTER IT SAYS- IN REGARDS
TO A 25% REDUCTION OVER A THREE
MONTH PERIOD OF TIME OVER A
QUARTER WHICH IS THE LANGUAGE I
BELIEVE IN THE SECOND PPP
ALONE- IS IT THERE ARE 25%
REDUCTION PER QUARTER OR JUST
25% REDUCTION IN GROSS
RECEIPTS. YOUR OVER YOUR FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR. ALL RIGHT SO
MANY. NO NO I HAVE I'VE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS SO I TRYING TO GO
THROUGH THE ALL FIRST DIDN'T
FOR THE CLARIFICATION PURPOSES
WE DIDN'T DISPLAY WE HAD A AB
EIGHTY THE SENATE SIDE WE IT
BECAUSE WE GOT. BECAUSE THE
BILL BILL MUCH AND WE GOT THE
SENSE THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
GET CLOSER TO FULL CONFORMITY
WHICH WAS THE ORIGINAL GOAL- WE
PULLED THE BILL WHEN WE GOT.
THIS THAT WE COULD GET A LITTLE
BIT MORE SO WE DIDN'T START
LATE WE STARTED. WHEN OTHER
STATES BEGAN BUT WE- WE WANTED
TO GET AS CLOSE TO FULL
CONFORMITY AS WE COULD GET FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION- SO THAT'S
THE FIRST THING. THE SECOND
PART IS YES WE DID ONE FULL
CONFORMITY THE REGIONAL BILL IS
TWO BILLION WE HAVE NOT XBEE
HAVE NOW EXPANDED UP TO SIX
BILLION WHICH WILL ACTUALLY
INCLUDE CLUED PER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BETWEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND 85% OF THOSE
WHO GOT THE LOANS. SO AND THEN
ON THE 25% GROUP. THE 25% THE
WAY WE'VE CHOSE IT WAS BECAUSE
THE SECOND ROUND OF FUNDING
REQUIRED THAT 25% LOSS. SO
THAT'S HOW WE CAME TO THAT
NUMBER WAS THAT. INSTEAD OF
DOING WE HAD MANY INTEGRATIONS
COME TO US MANY SUGGESTIONS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
SELECTING INDUSTRIES NARROWING
IT WE DIDN'T WANT TO DO THAT I
DIDN'T WANT TO PUT THE MEMBERS
BACK IN A SITUATION WERE
PICKING. REALLY DEFINED WINNERS
AND LOSERS WHERE WE WERE SAYING
THAT IT WAS. OKAY FOR DOCTORS
BUT NOT BE TITIAN'S OR WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE OUR GOLF
COURSES WE WOULD GET IT AND-
ATTORNEYS WANT WHATEVER IT WAS
WE WANTED TO MAKE IT. AS
CONSISTENT. AS WELL AS
CONSISTENT WITH THE FEDERAL LAW
IS WE COULD AND- ON THE LAST
POINT WE ARE NOT ACTUALLY
TAXING THE GRANTS WE ARE
DISALLOWING. THE DEDUCTION FOR
THOSE PAYMENTS SO WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY TAXING GRANT SUGGESTS
OKAY SO NOW YOUR NEXT QUESTION
IS GO AHEAD. I'M GONNA KEEP
TRYING TO RUN. NO I'VE AND THE
REASON IT'S A IS THAT THE- WAS.
IS A TWO FIVE PER READ. PER
CORE. OR TWENTY FIVE PER RATE.
YEAR OVER YEAR. I DON'T I'M NOT
SURE FOR THE TWENTY PRIVATE
ACTION A RECORDER YEAR YEAR BUT
ANY KIND. WITH THE FEDERAL LAW
WITH THE SECOND ROUND OF GRANTS
IF I UNDERSTAND UP TO THE
SECOND ROUND OF GRANTS THE
SECOND THE PPP LOAN DOES NOT
REGARD TO TAX CONFORMITY THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT APPLES APPLES AND
ORANGES. I UNDERSTAND THE
FORMULAS 25% RATE SO IF
SOMEBODY WANTED TO GET THE
SECOND PPP ALONE THEY WOULD HAD
HAVE SHOWN A 25% REDUCTION
RIGHT THAT'S IT SEPARATE- A
SEPARATE FEDERAL LAW. IN A
SEPARATE FEDERAL LAW THEN.
THERE IS A ONE TIME EVENT NO I
MEAN- O. J.'S ALL OF I'LL JAN
IT BUT I GOING TO JERRY STILLER.
YES I'M HERE YEAH- SO THE
ANSWER OF IS YES. IS THAT. IT
WOULD BE. 25% AND A- QUARTER.
CHAU TOOK A PERCENT CAUGHT. IN
ANY QUARTER TWENTY TWO FOUR FOR
THE ENTIRE YEAR. SO BUT STILL
UNDER AS IT IS THIS IS NOT IN
THE IN. AND I FIND IT IN THE
WAY. OF THE HOW THAT BE HOW
THAT BE SHOWN. ON THE RETURN
WHEN YOU FILE YOUR TAX. YOU
FILE A TAX RETURN FOR THE OF
TWENTY TWO. YOU DON'T SHE ON
YOUR TO RETURN- THAT- YOU KNOW
QUARTER BY QUARTER. SO HOW
WOULD THAT BE CHAU AND HOW YOU
PROVE. I CAN'T HOW WE HELL THAT
WOULD BE DONE- IT'S IT DID SAME.
THING OF EVIDENCE SHE WOULD.
FOR- FORGETTING THE SECOND
RIGHT. MMHM SO AS- SO THAT TO
BE WITH HAVE TO ANSWER EXACTLY
HOW THEY MONTH. PUT ON TO THE
TAX RETURNS I DOUBT DON'T
TAXPAYERS THANK YOU GIVE YOU
THE DETAILS OF HOWEVER. IF YOU
QUALIFIED THIS I ROUND OF WHAT
I. DOCUMENT TO YOU. TO QUALIFY
FOR THE SECOND ROUND OF ONE. IS
WHAT ARE INTO. IS FOR YOU TO
CALL. FOR THIS FOR A I FIND AS
A DOCTOR AND- THE AND THEN THIS
IS A- BUT- I KNOW MADAM CHAIR
THE THAT YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK ON NO I'M JUST TRYING.
THINK THE THIS ONE SO NEW ONCE
A YOU COULD ME THROUGH THE NEW.
THE CONCERN YOU THE I COULD.
BETTER HELP UNDERSTAND THEN THE
NEW ON THE NEW WANTS IS- THAT
THERE GOING TO BE. IN LOT OF
BUSINESS AND CAL. THAT HAD GOT-
THE LOAN FORGIVENESS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT'S NOT TAX.
TO THEM AND CAL. IS TO- THAT
AND THE IT'S A- CLEAR QUESTION.
IS IT IS THE ONLY RE 220% WERE.
OVER A- OR THAT IT'S FIVE PER
REDUCTION OVER THE ENTIRE THE
END YEAR I THOUGHT HE SAID-
OVER THE. RIGHT SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTION THEN IS. AND THIS IS
NOT THAT TYPE THIS IS NOT THAT
TECH. THE FOLLOW UP. IS HOW IS.
DONE THROUGH THE FRENCH. TAX
FORTY IT- IF IT'S ONLY. BY
QUARTER. I HAVE. WAS HOW WAS
THAT DONE BY. WHEN YOU YOUR WO
RETURN. IT'S YOUR GROW RECEIPTS
FOR THE ANTI YEAR IN NOT BROKE
DOWN. BY QUARTER RIGHT AND
FIRST LET'S GO BACK TO. WE ARE
NOT TAXING ANYONE FLOWN YOU
KEEP SAYING IT I KNOW YOU THINK
YOU DON'T BUT YOU KEEP SAYING
WE'RE TAXING ALONE WE ARE NOT.
WE'RE ALLOWING THE DEDUCTION.
IS A DIFFERENT I MEAN I KNOW
YOU DO TAXES BUT I MEAN I HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS COMMITTEE FROM
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS BILL.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE IN WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. SO THERE MAY BE
A NEW ONCE MISS UNDERSTANDING
AS TO WHAT THE ACTUAL BILL IS
DOING. IT IS ALLOWING THE
TAXPAYER TO MAKE THE
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER THEY.
QUALIFY FOR THE DEDUCTION. AND
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THIS OFFLINE
YOU CAN HOLD OFF YOUR BOAT
THAT'S FINE. AND I CAN LOG WE
CAN WALK YOU THROUGH IT. BUT WE
ARE NOT TAXING A GRANT OR LOAN
WHICH YOU SAID TWICE IT'S NOT
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE WE'RE
ALLOWING THE DEDUCTION. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE LIKE WE- J. IS
THAT CORRECT. YEAH THAT THAT'S
EXACTLY CORRECT. THIS IS A TAX
BENEFIT THAT WE ARE GIVING TO
TAXPAYERS IN THE CONFORMITY AND
SO INTENSE IT OFF IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT HARMING THE REGISTRY SO
THOSE WHO DON'T QUALIFY FOR THE
CONFORMITY OR JUST GETTING
TREATED THE WAY THEY WOULD
NORMALLY BE TREATED UNDER UNDER
TAX LAW. I THINK IF I CAN JUST
ONE MORE ONE MORE QUESTION HOW
MANY STATES- THAT HOW MANY
STATES. ARE ALLOWING FULL
CONFORMITY AND HOW MANY STATES
ARE SAYING. THAT WERE USES 25%
THRESHOLD. THE A HARD TO ANSWER
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE SO MANY OF US
FELL INTO THIS PROBLEM WITH THE
U. S. TREASURY RIGHT SO WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED THIS BILL.
ALTHOUGH WE DID WE WERE NOT
PROVIDING FULL CONFORMITY YOU
WERE ALLOWED TO PROVIDE FULL
CONFORMITY MOST STATES ARE A
LOT OF STATES EXCEPT FOR A
HANDFUL. HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR
PERMISSION FROM THE U. S.
TREASURY. TO ACTUALLY DO THE TO
ACTUALLY PASS THESE BILLS
WITHOUT LOSING OUR FEDERAL
FUNDING. SO ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION I DON'T THINK IT'S
GONNA IT'LL- I UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU'RE ASKING AND IF I ANSWER
IT HONESTLY I THINK OR IF WE
ANSWERED HONESTLY I THINK YOU
GET A SHORTCOMING ON WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T BECAUSE ALL
OF THE STATE'S WE WEREN'T ALONE
IN BEING PUT ON HOLD. OTHER
STATES ARIZONA OTHER STATES
WERE PUT ON HOLD LIKE WE WERE.
BECAUSE OF THE BECAUSE OF THE
PASSING OF THE KOPET ACT. THE
CODE. OKAY SO WE DON'T I CAN'T
GIVE YOU A PRECISE ANSWER
BECAUSE SO MANY ARE IN PROCESS
LIKE WE ARE LATE BECAUSE OF IT
IN FACT FINALLY FIND IF I CAN.
EXCELLENT IN THAT MADAM CHAIR I
AM GONNA LAY OFF TODAY- THIS
WAS A BILL THAT I WAS VERY
EXCITED ABOUT SEEING- AND- AND
I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
IT. UP RIGHT AWAY- IF I CAN
JUST MAKE ONE OTHER COMMENTARY
I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE- THAT-
AND I KNOW THAT- BUT THAT THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS DONE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK I
JUST WISH THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
I'M HAD THE ABILITY TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS I WISH THAT-
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE.
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE NEGOTIATING POWER IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE WANT A FULL
CONFORMITY- AND YET WE DIDN'T
GET A FULL CONFORMITY- AND MY
GUESS IS. THAT WE PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE HAD THE VOTES TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
LEVERAGE TO GET FULL CONFORMITY
SO- I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER BASS I AM.
JUST JUST- I KNOW THERE'S A FEW
MORE COMMITTEE MAY WHO WAS. BUT
JUST TO ADD TO. J- MISTER.
CHAMBERLAIN YOU MAY EARLIER-
THAT THIS COULD BE 25%
QUARTERLY OR TWICE FIRST
ANNUALLY AND MY CALL WHAT HIS
QUESTION HOW DO YOU DO TO. WHAT
DOCUMENTS DO YOU GIVE BECAUSE
HE'S RIGHT IS THAT WHEN WE DO
OUR TAXES WE DO IT ANNUALLY WE
DON'T DO BY QUARTER SHE SAID
QUARTERLY OR ANNUALLY. HOW DOES
THAT WORK HOW DO YOU PROVE THAT
IF YOU'RE TAX IS DONE BY
ANNUALLY. RIGHT SO YEAH THAT
THERE IT WOULD NOT BE SOMETHING
THAT THAT WOULD SHOW UP ON.
THE- ON THE TAX RETURN- IT
WOULD IT WOULD BE I. I DON'T
HAVE TO BE A THE LINE THAT'S
YOUR EXACT HOW IT. HOW CAUGHT
UP HAVE BUT I IT WOULD BE A
SOFTWARE. THAT THE- I THE
TAXPAYER WOULD HAVE TO- DO WITH
THE DO THE- I'M JUST LIKE THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN WANT TO BE GET
THE- THAT. LOAN SECOND ROUND
LOS- BUT- I'M- BUT I BELIEVE
THEY WOULD THEY WOULD TO STOP
TEST TO MEDIAN THAT STAND AND
THEN ABLE TO THAT UPON AUDIT-
BUT I DO BELIEVE TO BE IS HERE
WANTED TO THEM. GET THEIR-
THEIR INSIGHT. IS THERE SOME.
AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON YOUR
QUESTION LOCAL COPS. GO AHEAD
PLEASE FORM- I WOULD. THANK YOU
I WOULD AGREE WITH CAME NOT
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WOULD
REPORTED ON THE RICH AND THAT
AMOUNT OF DETAIL IT WOULD
SOMETHING THAT- PAUL BUSINESS
ENTITY WHAT IF WILL CALL. AND
THEN WOULD AFTER INPUT TO THAT-
OF COURSE THAT IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE OR NOT ONE THING THAT
WE WILL VERY QUICKLY DO PROVIDE
ANOTHER CONSTRUCTION SHOULD TO
BE ABLE TO USE THAT INFO CALL A
RETURN. THANK YOU. JUST REAL
QUICK CAN I CAN I SOMEBODY PER
ME THAT AND UNDERSTAND AND TRY
TO GET THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR-
QUICKLY IS THAT POSSIBLE FOR ME
TO GET CLAY WITHIN BUT AT THE
ACTUAL THAT THAT IT'S QUARTER%
BY QUARTER VERSUS A YEAR OVER
YEAR. YEAH I MEAN I'M JUST. NOT
SOMEBODY LISTEN. ANSWERS THOUGH.
MISTER WOULD BE ABLE OR FROM
THE FTP ON GOING TO HOLD THE
BILL THAT I'M I'M NOT A THEM
YOU KNOW NO I'M I'M ANSWERING
AND I USING THE PEOPLE NEED TO
THIS DYING AND I'M THE F. BE
WILL BE TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
KNOW IF HAVE TO POOR IF THEY
NEED TO AUDIT THE TO CONFIRM
THAT THAT THAT THEY IN THAT
TWENTY THAT. MAY THEY RECEIVE
THE STUCK ROUND OF FUNNY THAT
REQUIRE THE 25% THE REQUIRED
PAPER. TO SHOW THAT 25% I AM NO
DOUBT THAT THEY HAVE TO BE CAN
MANAGE THAT. HOWEVER THESE BUT
THIS BILL AS YOURSELF AND
DOCTOR CREEK HAVE MENTIONED ARE
LONG OVERDUE SO WE ARE NOT
GOING TO PUT THEM ON PAUSE FOR
ANOTHER DAY PEOPLE NEED TO GET.
THESE BUSINESSES NEED THESE
BUSINESS NEEDS NEED TO GET THAT
THIS THEIR TAXES DONE. THEY'VE
SOME HAVE FILED EXTENSION SOME
ARE TRYING TO WAIT. NOT JUST
THE BUSINESSES BUT THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK THERE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS GETS DONE IN A
TIMELY FASHION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. MISTER
KELLY. THANK YOU SIR THE ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION ABOUT WHO SORT
THIS OUT AS THE PERSON DOING
THE TAXES MY WIFE- THEY HAVE TO
GET TOGETHER WITH THE BUSINESS
OWNERS AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT BASED ON ALL OF
THE DATA THAT THEY CAN COLLECT
FROM THE BUSINESS OWNER THE
RECORDS IT'S ADDRESS AND FIGURE
OUT THAT OUT AND THIS WHOLE TAX
CONFORMITY ISSUE IS ONE THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF ISSUES- REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF- OF CONFUSION- AND
PAPERWORK. AND STREAMLINE IT SO
THAT THESE TACTICS ACTUALLY GET
DONE RIGHT NOW THERE IS A
BACKLOG FOR EVERY TAX
PROFESSIONAL OF ALL OF THESE
CLIENTS THAT ARE WAITING FOR
THIS THIS SAID THIS TO COME
THROUGH AND- SO- YEAH ANOTHER
COMMENT I HAVE IS YOU KNOW IT
WHILE THE TAX DEDUCTION. IS NOT
A TAX. IF YOU ARE NOT A TO IF
YOU'RE DEDUCTING TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS COULD YOU GET A CREDIT
OR DEBIT TAX DEDUCTION. AND
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO PAY TAXES ON THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO WINDS UP
BEING LIKE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS INSTEAD IT YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT AND- IT'S NOT IT BUT
SO THERE IS. AN AMOUNT OF TAX
THAT DOES HAPPEN- BUT- BECAUSE
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE
ARE IN RIGHT NOW. THERE IS A
LOT MORE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE HELPED BY THIS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE HEARD. AND IF
WE IF WE HOLD THIS UP ORG.
ACTUALLY WE'RE NOT GOING TO-
THEN THOSE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
ARE HURTING AND NEEDED HELP.
NOW ARE NOT GOING TO GET THE
HELP THEY NEED- I FULLY. HAVE
THE SAME CONCERNS AS MR QUIRK
MISTER MAYES- BUT WE NEED TO
MOVETHIS THING FORWARD. TO
HELP THESE BUSINESSES OUT NOW.
AND TO GET THE TAX
PROFESSIONALS WORKING OUT
THERE- THE DEADLINE NOW IS MAY
TWENTY ARE MAY SEVENTEENTH. AND
THEY'RE ALL UNDER THE GUN
THEY'RE ALL WAITING FOR THIS.
SO WE NEED TO GET IT DONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- AND I REALLY
WANT TO. JUST ECHO MISTER SAY
ARTISTS COMMENTS I THINK THAT A
LOT OF US YOU KNOW WOULD LOVE
TO SEE MORE OR DIFFERENT THINGS
IN THIS BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS CERTAINTY THAT'S THE
THING THAT'S BEEN HURTING MOST
BUSINESSES THEY JUST WANT TO
KNOW HOW TO REPORT AND HOW TO
PAY THEIR TAXES. SO THE ONLY
THING THAT I'LL SAY DIFFERENT.
YES THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
WHAT WHAT I THINK WAS TASK I
YOU KNOW I HAVE HAVE GOTTEN SO
MANY. EMAILS AND CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE SAID WHEN
IS THIS THING GOING TO GET DONE
WE JUST WANT TO DO OUR TAXES-
NOT. I WANT TO GET AWAY WITHOUT
PAYING TAXES THEY JUST WANT TO
DO THEIR TAXES THEY'RE GOOD
AMERICANS THEY'RE GOOD
CALIFORNIANS ANSWER THANKS THE
AUTHOR- FOR SHEPHERDING US
THROUGH. THANK. WELL AND I ALSO
I ALSO DO AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR- I DO SHARE THE CONCERNS
I THINK IF OF MANY ON THIS
COMMITTEE I AM THAT I WISH WE
HAD BEEN ABLE TO DELIVER FULL
CONFORMITY I RECOGNIZE THAT AT
THE THIS IS CERTAINLY A FAR
BETTER THAN NOTHING AND BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS REALLY
480% OF IMPACTED BUSINESSES IS
GOOD I DO WORRY ABOUT THOSE
OTHER TWENTY PERCENT- SO I
THINK IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE ABLE IF YOU
COULD HELP THIS COMMITTEE AND I
THINK OTHERS UNDERSTAND THE
CONTEXT OF. IT WHY ARE WE-
GOING WITH THIS 25% GIVEN THAT
YOU. AS THE AUTHOR WENT FULL
CONFORMITY. MINIBUSES CO
AUTHORS WANT FULL CONFORMITY.
YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS THE
COST YOU KNOW I STARTED OUT
WITH THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR
BILL IT'S NOW A SIX BILLION
DOLLAR BILL IN FULL CONFORMITY
IS. A LITTLE OVER EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S REALLY A FUNCTION
OF THIS ISN'T THE ONLY BILL
THAT WE'VE DONE TO TRY TO
ALLEVIATE THE STRESS IS A
BUSINESS. I CALL AND EVERYONE
LISTEN THERE'S NOT A PERSON ON
THIS COMMITTEE THAT DOESN'T
KNOW THAT. THAT I AM FULLY
SUPPORT OF A SMALL BUSINESS AND
BUSINESS IN GENERAL AND. EVERY
SINGLE PERSON THAT THEY EMPLOY-
THE REALITIES THAT SOME. YOU
OUT OF MY- AND WE WERE PART OF
A PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT THAT
YOU KNOW HOW TO SIGNIFICANT
COST AND WE HUNG OUT ALMOST
EQUALLY CONFIDENT THAT
SIGNIFICANT. BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THAT SIGNIFICANT PACKAGE- AND
THAT'S REALLY THAT LONG AND THE
SHORT OF IT IS REALLY NOT MUCH
MORE COMPLICATED THAN THAT.
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATING
IT'S BEEN THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
HAS BEEN AMAZING AND THEY
PUSHED VERY VERY HARMFUL
CONFORMITY WITH US AS WELL- YOU
KNOW. SOMETIMES IT'S JUST WE
JUST CAN'T QUITE GET THERE AND
FROM WHERE WE STARTED LIKE I
SAID FOR THOSE OF YOU HAVE WHO
HAVE LOOKED AT EIGHTY. FROM ITS
ORIGINAL FORM. THIS IS. MUCH
FURTHER THAN WE WERE. WE ARE
SEVENTY SEVEN AUTHORS DEEP ON
THIS BILL WE PUT AS MUCH
PRESSURE. AS ANYONE COULD PUT.
YOU KNOW ON THE ADMINISTRATION
I MEAN SEVENTY SEVEN MEMBERS A
SEVENTY SEVEN MEMBERS AND
SENATORS YOU KNOW THAT'S A LIE.-I DON'T KNOW THE LAST TIME I
SAW A BILL WITH THAT MANY
AUTHORS THAT. STUCK WITH IT NO
MATTER WHAT THE ADORATION WAS.
SO YOU KNOW AT THE END OF THE
DAY. YES WOULD FULL CONFORMITY
BEEN NICE DID I THINK I MIGHT
MAKE IT THERE I DIDN'T FOR A
BIT. BUT WE DID IT AND THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS AT THIS
POINT. SIX SERVING 85% OF THOSE
WHO HAVE HAVE STRUGGLED OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND WHO DID THE
RIGHT THING. WHO SPENT THE
MONEY ON THE RIGHT THINGS IS
SOMETHING TO BE PROUD OF. AND I
ALSO WILL TELL YOU THIS YOU
KNOW THOSE WHO DIDN'T HAVE A
25% LAWS. YOU KNOW THIS WINTER
FOR PEOPLE WHO WERE STRUCK WERE
FOR COMPANIES YOU KNOW WHO ARE
STRUGGLING AND SO IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S HARD TO BALANCE THAT OUT.
BUT I FEEL VERY PROUD THAT
WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT 85% OF
THE BUSINESSES I THINK THOSE
WHO. DON'T VOTE FOR IT. I HAVE
FORGOTTEN ABOUT THE 85% OF
THOSE BUSINESSES AND ALL OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY KEPTON THEIR
PAYROLL. WITH THIS MONEY. SO
THAT'S MY ANSWER. THE SCENE NO
MORE COMMENTS IF I MAY JUST SAY
A FEW WORDS MADAM CHAIR- I YOUR
SISTER CONCERNS WITH CALLING I
WISH WAS FOR OF FOOD CONFORM.
OF BUT- EITHER IT IS A I WAS
JUST MADE OF THIS. FRIDAY OF BY
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE- IN REGARDS
TO THE 25% AND SO YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S ANOTHER WAY MAYBE LATER
ON- THE VIEW WOULD CONSIDER WE
LOOKING AT THE 25% OR IN AN
OPTION OF OTHER WAYS TO HELP I
THINK- THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED AND I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU IT IT IS A THANKLESS
CHOPPING YOU WORKED REALLY HARD
TO HIDE I KNOW THAT BECAUSE I
WOULD GET TEXT MESSAGES AND
CALLS FROM YOU SAY HEY WE'RE
STILL WORKING. ON WHICH TO- I'M
PULLING IT I. WORK ON ITS- NO
GREATLY A- AND- YOU KNOW I WISH
WE- HAD FULL. I'VE I GUESS SURE
WHAT MY CALL. THIS IS THE RIGHT
BILL THE NEED TO GO FORWARD.
BECAUSE THERE ARE 85% OF THE
OTHER BUSINESSES AS WELL- BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW THERE I'M
HOPEFUL THAT MAYBE THERE'S
OTHER OPTIONS THAT WE CAN
ASSIST IN OTHER WAYS- IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS OR SO A MONTH
BEFORE THE END OF SESSION AS
WELL SO. THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME- WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TOO MANY CLOSE UP THAT'S
RIGHT CAN YOU PLEASE CLOSE YET
FIRST OFF I WANT TO TELL YOU
WHEN I WHEN I TOLD THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHICH IS THIS
IS PROBABLY THE FIRST REVENUE
TAX BILL THAT I HAVE SEEN SUCH
PERSISTENT AND CONSISTENT
ATTENTION AND I AM JUST SO
GRATEFUL TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
ALL THE MEMBERS. OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE WHO STAYED
ON THIS ISSUE IT WAS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE IT LAGGED
BEHIND FOR A LITTLE BIT IT FELT
LIKE IT WOULD NEVER GET DONE
AND IT'S ONLY BECAUSE OF THAT
PERSISTENT AND CONSISTENT
PUSHING BY ALL OF YOU THAT THAT
WERE EVEN THIS FAR INTO IT SO.
I JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR PUSHING AS HARD AS THEY
HAVE AND FOR NOT FORGETTING
THAT YOU KNOW THESE BUSINESSES
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT AND YOU
KNOW I KNOW EVERYONE HAS A LOT
OF BILLS BUT KEEPING THIS ONE
IN LINE WITH WAS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME AND WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF PEOPLE SO
THANK YOU GUYS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I. THANK
YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO
RECOMMEND CONCURRENCE. IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. MISS
HIGHLAND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I FIND RIGHT. RIGHT NOT MOVING.
REASON LOOKING. YEAH THERE THIS
IS NOT MULLIN. HI- ARTICLE- I
WORK ON. NEGATIVE YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY. CHAIR IN
COLLEAGUES AND PROUD PRESENT
BILL C. FIVE WHICH WOULD A STEP
THE FOR STATEWIDE UNIV BASIC
INCOME PRO IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY A CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME WOULD PROVIDE
ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS WITH A
THOUSAND DOLLARSPER MONTH AND
UNCONDITIONAL CASH PAYMENTS IN
ORDER PROVIDE RECIPIENTS WITH
THE BASIC LEVEL OF ECONOMIC
SECURITY. THE ESTORE CRIES IN
INCOME INEQUALITY WERE
EXPERIENCE IN THE UNITED STATES
COMBINED WITH THE DEADLY
PANDEMIC REQUIRES THIS THESE
TYPE OF BOLD SOLUTIONS. MORE
THAN 36% OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ARE. OR AT NEARBY LAW
ACCORDING TO OURS BUREAU IN
FACT THAT MAY A VERY THAT ONE
THREE CALIFORNIA'S EITHER LIVED
IN POVERTY OR THEY'RE JUST ONE
BAD DAY AWAY FROM THE COMING
HOMELESS. TODAY NO ONE WOULD
SUGGEST GETTING RID OF A SUCH.
BENEFITS AS UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION AND- I AM HOPEFUL
THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS WILL BE
SAYING THE SAME ABOUT UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME. AS WE KNOW MOST
AMERICANS ARE UNABLE TO AFFORD
A FOUR HUNDRED DOLLAR
UNEXPECTED EMERGENCY. JUST FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS CAN ENDANGER
THEIR ABILITIES SURVIVE
COMFORTABLY. AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF BASIC INCOME PROGRAMS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN.
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND
EFFECTIVE IN THE CITY OF
STOCKTON LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO LONG BEACH AND MOSCOW
THAT WOULD ARE ALSO EXPLORING
UNIVERSAL BASIC PROGRAMS. THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN UP AND
UNIVERSAL BASIC. INCOME POLICY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARIA.
I AM THE WIFE AB MANGE
INDIVISIBLE A NOT NON.
ORGANIZATION COMMITTING ALL THE
VOICE AND TOLD THE BOOK ACROSS
AND X. I CAN UP TO. FOR
EIGHTEEN. POINT OLD. I AM PROUD
TO A LONGTIME MEMBER OF A LOW A
MEMBER WHO'S VERY OWN DISHED
FROM ON THE AND- WILL OF THE
LAW TO COME SUICIDE. AND I
TRULY COME HIM FOR ON OUR STATE
TO HAVE BASS. FUNDAMENTALS OF
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR EVERY. BUT
CHALLENGES ADULTS OUR FUTURE.
FROM TUITION AND NOT THE CAR
UNDER. HOW CARE FOR THE BILL.
THANK HELLO. BUT I STATE THREE
ANOTHER OF LOCAL. WE CHALLENGE
ARE FAR MORE SHOULD BE THAN
PREVIOUS YEARS. WE NEED TO WORK
SO NOT. IT'S TIME TO SONSTIGE
ECONOMIC SECURE FOR TODAY IT'S
TIME TO BUCKLE BY TOWN SUPPORT.
TO GENERATE LIVING THE- COST
CRISIS. WE ARE NOW TO. THAT IS
LIKELY TO AN FHA. AND BECOME A
TIME HOME BUYER I GENERATE LESS
TO TAKE A RISK. FIRST INCOME
HAVE YOU BLOWN POPULARITY
BOOSTING. FROM CITY LIKE STOCK
ALEC. NATIONAL TENNESSEE AND
EVEN JACK DORSEY TO IT'S-
RECENTLY MOVED EIGHT OF THE ARE
WELL. TOO SMART L. L. C. IF
YOU'RE WILL CANNELLA LEAST AND
U. B. I. INCOME CROWD.
ACCORDING UNITED STATES AND
GIRL. COLLECTIVE THE HOUSEHOLD
SURVEY. A YEAR AFTER CONDEMNING
DAY SHOW THAT 50% OFF ONE OF
THE EIGHT EIGHT VERY REPORTER
LOSS OF INCOME IN THE- AT THE
START THE NEXT 30% REPORT
DIFFICULTY PAYING FOR HEALTH IS.
10% REPORTER THE OFF DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH EAT THE PREVIOUS.
40% OF CALIFORNIAN BETWEEN SAME
AGE. WILL COURT WITH CHILDREN
IN THEIR HOUSE THAT THEY WERE
IN THEIR CHILDREN WERE NOT
UNION BECAUSE THE JUDGE COULD
NOT. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU AND I WOULD NOT LIKE
TO PASS IT ON TO CERTAINLY
BENNETT A RESIDENT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE BENNETT I'M A WIFE
AND A MOM OF TWO DAUGHTERS AN
ELEVEN YEAR OLD AND A SEVEN
YEAR OLD AND WE LIVE IN CENTRAL
VALLEY. LAST SPRING AFTER
TWELVE YEARS OF HARD WORK I
FINALLY GRADUATED AND RECEIVED
MY BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM
FRESNO STATE UNIVERSITY. AND
THERE ARE MANY REASONS IT TOOK
TWELVE YEARS. UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME COULD HAVE HELPED ME AT
THIS TIME AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE YOU. JUST A SMALL PORTION
OF HOW IT COULD HELP THAT. EVEN
WITH MY HUSBAND WORKING A FULL
TIME JOB IN THE RECEIVING
FINANCIAL AID WE COULDN'T
AFFORD GAS OR CHILD CARE. THE
WAIT LIST FOR CHILD CARE WAS
TOO LONG SO I WOULD NEVER
GUARANTEED A SPOT FOR MY CHILD
AT SCHOOL AND WITHOUT CHILD
CARE I COULDN'T WORK WITH WHILE
I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL. I
ATTENDED TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO THAT I CAN STAY ONLINE
CLASSES AROUND MY HUSBAND'S
WORK SCHEDULE WHICH MEANT I
NEEDED TO FILL UP MY GAS TANK
MORE OFTEN. GOING TO SCHOOL
DIDN'T JUST MEAN ATTENDING
CLASSES IT MEANT FORCING MY
FAMILY TO LIVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK. THIS CONSTANT
FINANCIAL STRUGGLE MADE ME.
STOP AND RESTART MY EDUCATION
SEVERAL TIMES. A UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME COULD HELP
ALLEVIATE THIS PART OF MY
PROBLEM THE SCHOOL. DEMANDED
THAT I COULD HAVE AFFORDED TO
FILL MY GAS TANK UP PAPER CHILD
CARE OR HELP ME PROVIDE. AND
FINE CLOTHES BUY CLOTHES THAT
FIT MY GROWING TODDLERS. FOR
FAMILIES LIKE MINE A UPI COULD
MEAN WE GET TO FINISH HER
EDUCATION IN A TIMELY MANNER
WHILE HAVING THE ROOM TO
BREATHE WHILE PROVIDING PART
FAMILIES. I WANT TO SHOW MY
DAUGHTER THAT A HIGHER
EDUCATION IS ESSENTIAL AND IT'S
POSSIBLE. I DID NOT WANT THEM
TO SEE IT AS A BURDEN OR A LONG
HAUL AS IT WAS FOR MYSELF. I
HOPE THAT YOU ALL BUT THIS
THROUGH AND PLEASE CONSIDER THE
IMPACT YOU COULD HAVE ON YOUNG
ADULT AND WORKING FAMILIES LIKE
MINE. THANK YOU. MODERATOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVER TO ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JOHN CALLING FROM NSW
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
GREAT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN THE VIDEO TESTIMONIES CENTER.
I'M GUESSING WELL I THINK I CAN
ANSWER OKAY NOW ANYWHERE. IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS WISHING TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN. THE LINE. HI THIS IS A
COUPLE OF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. ALL RIGHT- WHILE
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
LOCKDOWNS MAINTENANCE PAYMENTS
NECESSARY TO THOSE OUT OF WORK
AND STRUGGLING TO GET BY A
CONTINUING STIMULUS PROGRAM AND
ITS ASSOCIATED ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS DOES NOT SEEM NECESSARY
AT THIS TIME THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALREADY CAPABLE OF ISSUING
TEMAS PAYMENTS CALIFORNIANS IN
NEED ON AN AS NEEDED BASIS AND
IT'S DONE SO FURTHER THE PRE
PANDEMIC ARGUMENT FOR YOU BE I
TENDED TO HINGE ON A PARTICULAR
ROBOT DUE TO TECHNOLOGICAL
UNEMPLOYMENT. ABOUT SOME JOBS
HAVE BEEN MADE OBSOLETE BY
TECHNOLOGY OTHERS TAKE THEIR
PLACE THE FEAR DOESN'T SQUARE
WITH REALITY FURTHER PROGRAMS
ALREADY EXIST TO RETRAIN OUR
WORKERS AS WELL AS BILLION
SPENT ON EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
HOMELESS SERVICES ND OTHER
DIRECT AND INDIRECT BENEFIT
PROGRAMS IF OUR CURRENT
PROGRAMS ARE NOT LIVING UP TO
EXPECTATIONS WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THOSE PROGRAMS WORK BETTER
BEFORE LITERALLY THROWING MONEY
AT THE PROBLEM. I ASK YOU TO
VOTE NO THANK YOU. MODERATOR IF
YOU. THE LINE FOR ANY. WHEN
ENOUGH. PLEASE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB SIXTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU HAVE TWO LINES THANK
YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT
FOR THE FIRST COMMENT.
AND
WE'RE GOING TO ONE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AND MINE
COMMITTEE AND I IN THE RIGHT
PLACE WITH THE TAXES IS IT IS
THAT THE TAX COMMITTEE I WANT
TO MAKE SURE I'M IN THE RIGHT
PLACE THE CALL ON ALWAYS FOR
THAT YES YOU'RE IN THE RIGHT
PLACE. THANK YOU. ARE YOU
TESTING. GOOD I'M FIGHTING
AGAINST THIS BUT I'D LIKE TO BE
A PRIMARY WITNESS SINCE YOU
DIDN'T HAVE TO WITHOUT A
PROBLEM I AM A CALIFORNIAN
AFTER ALL YOU'RE SO YOU NEED TO
REGISTER BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. BUT I WOULD THINK
THAT YOU WOULD WANT
REPRESENTATION ON. AND WE ARE
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE AND THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING. I GUESS
TO SORT OF ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
STELMACH MAN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN
THE VIDEO TESTS A PENNY VIDEO
TESTIMONY CENTER. NO SEEING
NONE- ANY NO ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE AS
WELL ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WE WILL GO.
MOVE THE BILLS OUT A SECOND
OKAY I'LL GO THIS WAY. NO NO
YEAH I KNOW YOU HAVE A
QUESTION- SO KILEY I THINK HER
HAND UP AND THEN MISTER SEA
ARTURO. AND THEN ADAM WILL GO
AROUND THE BACK. CAN YOU TALK
US THROUGH A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
THE SPECIFICS OF THE PROPOSAL.
THE QUESTIONS I HEARD AT THE
SPECIFICS OF THE OF THE
PROPOSAL. YES HAVE AS YOU MAY
KNOW THEY A PROPOSAL IS ON
UNIVERSAL UNCONDITIONAL BASIC
INCOME AS WE'VE SEEN SIMILAR
ITERATIONS OF A STIMULUS. CASH
PAYMENTS GOING DIRECTLY TO
INDIVIDUALS ON THIS WOULD BE A
SIMILAR TYPE OF INTEGRATION OF
THE THOUSAND DOLLAR BENEFITS
AS- REFLECT IN THE COMING NOW
SAYS THEIR NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN OUTLINED. I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ESPECIALLY
AS I'VE INTRODUCED THIS
ACTUALLY FOR THE SECOND YEAR
HAVE REQUESTED A SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THIS TO HELP FOR
THE IRON OUT SOME OF THE POLICY
ISSUES. OF THIS COMMITTEE-
STRIPPED OUT THE FUNDING
MECHANISM TOWARDS IT- AND SO
THIS PROVIDES US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT THE POLICY ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION. WE GIVEN
THAT OF THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AND ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
AND HOW INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
RECEIVE SUCH BASIC INCOME
PAYMENTS- SO THAT IS THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US
WHICH IS THAT OF. AND GIVING
THAT AUTHORITY TO THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD ON THE ELIGIBILITY OF
INDIVIDUALS TO RECEIVE THESE
CASH PAYMENTS WORKING THAT
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE TO BEST
DETERMINE WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE. AND WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
AS REFLECT IN THE ANALYSIS
DEMONSTRATES THAT OF THIS THIS
CONFLICT WITH OTHER TYPE OF
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
HAVE ANOTHER SIMILAR- SISTER
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DOES NOT COMPETE THAT STACKED
WITH. ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS WE
DON'T WANT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES INDIVIDUALS NOT TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER SOCIAL
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS TO ALSO
RECEIVE THESE PAYMENTS AS WELL
TOO SO. AS WE HAVE THE BILL
BEFORE US THAT'S TO GIVE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THAT
AUTHORITY. AND SO THE PROPOSAL.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT IS THAT
WOULD BE A THOUSAND DOLLAR
MONTH PAYMENT FOR ANY
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN WITH SOME EXCLUSIONS
BURNING MORE. THAT 2100% OR
LESS OF THE MEDIAN RENTS FOR
THE DISTRICTS SO- YOU MENTION
THERE ISN'T A FUNDING MECHANISM
AND IT IS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BUT WHAT WHAT IS
THE ESTIMATE OF. THE. ANNUAL
COST OF A PROGRAM OF THAT. YOU
SIGNIFICANT- AND THAT THAT IS
PART OF THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE THAT I HAVE BEFORE US WHICH
IS TO HAVE A POLICY
CONVERSATION TO SEE WHAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION WILL LOOK LIKE
AND WHAT THE COST WOULD BE THE
DETERMINANT BUT HAN WHO WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT TYPE OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO WHAT TYPE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY IN
EXISTING PROGRAMS ALREADY HOW
DOES THIS WORK IN IN
COMPLEMENTARY WAS IT STACKED.
ALSO IDENTIFYING WHAT OTHER
LOCAL CITIES ARE DOING AND HOW
THAT IS IN COMPLEMENT TO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AS WELL. SO IF MY
MATH IS RIGHT AND IT MIGHT BE
WRONG BUT IF MY MATH IS RIGHT I
THINK THIS IS LIKE TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH
IS. THE CLEARLY WOULD BE A
DOUBLING OF OUR STATE'S BUDGET
IS THAT KIND OF BALLPARK WHAT
DO YOU THINK IT IS IT IS A
LARGE AMOUNT YES AND IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT. YES AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK- THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE CHAIRS AND
I'M TOTALLY STRIPPED. THAT'S
WHY I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY HAVE THE
FIRST HEARING US I'VE PROPOSED
THIS YES THIS IS A VERY POLL
PROPOSAL- AND BECAUSE- THE-
COMMITTEE CHAIR ALLOWED FOR THE
CONVERSATION AND THE FIRST
TIME. EVER TO BE. A HURT-
THAT'S PART OF THE CONVERSATION
TO SEE WHAT WITH THE POLICY
LOOK LIKE. ABSENT THAT OF THE
FUNDING MECHANISM. OKAY
UNDERSTOOD. OKAY AND AS I SAID
LOOK I CANNOT SUPPORT IT TODAY-
BUT THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION. OKAY OKAY-
SO EVERY RESIDENT DO WE HAVE A
RESIDENCY REQUIREMENT HOW LONG
YOU HAVE TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU
GET IT WHAT IS THAT RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS I WAS THE WERE
IRONED OUT SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
BUT CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. RIGHT
OKAY SO DOES OREGON WASHINGTON
NEVADA ARIZONA ALL THESE OTHER
STATES DO THEY HAVE THIS. DO
THEY HAVE THE REVERSE BASIC
INCOME YEAH NO AS I MENTIONED
IN THE- PRESENTATION THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT BRADY SO
AND WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
OTHER PILOTS. IN MANY CITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
GETTING AT HERE IS. E. ADD UP
THE NUMBER OF EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
GRADUATES FROM ALL THESE
DIFFERENT STATES I DON'T HAVE
IT. IN CALIFORNIA IS OFFERING
YOU TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO COME HANG OUT HERE WE
DON'T HAVE JOBS FOR THEM WE
DON'T HAVE HOUSES FOR THEM.
THAT'S PART OF THE POLICY
DISCUSSION THAT YOU NEED TO
HAVE ABOUT THIS- IS WHAT DO YOU
DO WITH ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU ARE LOWERING FROM OTHER
STATES THAT NOW BECOME
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THAT WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE ENOUGH JOBS FOR
THE ONES THAT WE HAVE HERE NOW.
WE DON'T HAVE HOUSES WERE THE-ONES WE HAVE HERE NOW. SO THAT
IS A HUGE CONCERN ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR PRICE
TAG ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY TO GET TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IS TO.
EXPAND THE ECONOMY THAT'S GONNA
TAKE A WHILE GIVEN OUR
CIRCUMVENT RESEARCH- I CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO THAT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN AND- YEAH IT
FRANKLY TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS- YOU KNOW GIVING GIVING
TO EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO DO WITH
WHAT THEY WANT- IS KIND OF A
RECIPE FOR SOCIAL DISASTER. AND
SO I'M NOT GONNA BE SUPPORTING
THIS ESPECIALLY IN ITS CURRENT
FORM I WOULD BE I WOULD BE OPEN
TO LISTENING TO SOMETHING ABOUT
REPLACING SOME OF OUR CURRENT-
THE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS INSTEAD OF
HAVING THIS MARY OUT OF
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. BUT THE
PRICE TAG IS TOO BIG TO LURE IS
TOO BIG AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
FRANKLY THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN'T HANDLE
ESPECIALLY GIVEN OUR- OUR A
PENCHANT FOR. HAVING YOU KNOW A
FAIRLY BUSINESS AND FRIENDLY
ENVIRONMENT AT THIS TIME SO. I
WON'T BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
THANK YOU. ADAM. MISTER GREG. I
DON'T MORE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I WON'T REPEAT THE
COMMENTS- THE MYCOLOGIST LAID
OUT AS FAR AS KIND OF THE- WHAT
WHAT AT FIRST BLUSH I THINK
DISTRICTS ALL OF US IS ALMOST
SORT RIGHT THE NOTION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO. DO A PROGRAM
AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
THIS LEGISLATURE- AND THESE
COMMENTS ARE DIRECTED AT THE
AUTHOR OF A DESTRUCTIVE BOND.
IS WE LOVE TO- MAKE LOFTY
PROMISES TO OUR POLITICAL BASE
PARTICULARLY MY COLLEAGUES
THAT- MY PARTY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WE LOVE TO SUGGEST THINGS
THAT THAT ARE TOTALLY NOT
REALISTIC. RIGHT UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE. SINGLE PAYER HERE
IN CALIFORNIA'S EXAMPLE RIGHT
JUST OUTRAGEOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THE STATE TAX SYSTEM
WOULDN'T EVEN SUPPORT. NOT THAT
IT'S NOT IMPORTANT DISCUSSION.
RIGHT AT ITS CORE MAKING SURE
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA HAS
HEALTH CARE. BOB IT'S SO. GIVEN
THAT YOUR BILL DOESN'T HAVE
FUNDING IN IT STRIP BY THIS
COMMITTEE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT CORRECT CORRECT YEAH- I
WANT I WANT TO TALK FOR MEN
ABOUT I THINK WHAT YOUR CORE.
VALUES RIGHT I THINK WHAT YOUR
CORE VLUES YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE AFFORDABLE
RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE HOW UNAFFORDABLE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BECOME
THE COST OF HOUSING THE COST OF
LIVING IN CENTER. AND THAT'S
AND THAT THAT'S SOMETHING WON'T
WORK WHERE I THINK WE'D FIND A
LOT OF- COMMON GROUND EVEN EVEN
WITH OUR FRIENDS ACROSS THE
AISLE RIGHT HOW DO WE MAKE. THE
ECONOMY CALIFORNIA WORK BETTER
ONE OF MY COMPLAINTS IS A
RURAL. CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE
SPEND 90% OF OUR TIME HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SOLVING URBAN
PROBLEMS. RIGHT AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS URBAN COMMUNITIES-
DON'T BUILD ENOUGH HOUSING TO
SUPPORT. THEIR COMMUNITIES
THEIR WORK FORCE AND SUCH GREAT
CREATE A SUPPLY DEMAND ISSUE
DRIVE UP THE COST OF HOUSING.
AND THE ANSWER TO THESE TYPES
OF PROBLEMS IS ALWAYS YOU KNOW
SUBSIDIES OR GOVERNMENT MONEY
AND THINGS THAT THAT THAT
FUNCTIONALLY. LONG TERM DON'T
WORK. I'VE OFTEN I THOUGHT WE
SHOULD RELITIGATE THE WAGE
MAKE MINIMUM WAGE HAVE THE SAME
BUYING POWER IN EVERY COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS DO IS WE SELL
WE PICK A NUMBER THAT WE THINK
SOUNDS GOOD THE PEOPLE LIKE CAN
WE GO WHAT THE FIGHT FOR TWELVE
THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN THE FIGHT
FOR TWENTY EIGHT. BUT WE NEVER
HAVE AN HONEST DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT IS FIFTEEN DOLLARS BUY. IN
PALO ALTO. PURSES OUT WATER. OR
VERSUS PLATTER- IT ENDS AND SO
I THINK THAT'S THE DISCUSSION
I'D LIKE TO ENGAGE WITH YOUR
SAUSAGE HOW DO WE MAKE THINGS
MORE EQUITABLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE RIGHT AND I THINK WE
START BY NOT VIEWING POLICY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO THE
MYOPIC LENS OF- CITY. CITY FOLK
CITY COMMUNITY. RIGHT- AND SO.
I'M GONNA LISTEN TO THE REST OF
THE DISCUSSION AND I'M GONNA
TRY TO MAINTAIN AN OPEN HEART
AND OPEN MIND ABOUT WHERE YOUR
MOTIVATIONS ARE AND MAYBE KEEP
THIS DISCUSSION GOING- BUT I
GOTTA SAY THE NOTION OF A
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME- I
PERSONALLY DON'T THINK- MAKES
LOTS OF SENSE I THINK IF WE'RE
GONNA GO DOWN THAT ROUTE WE
NEED TO. TAKE A DEEP LOOK AT
ALL OF THE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
RIGHT IN THE FOR SPENDING MONEY
CURRENTLY ON SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EFFECTIVE OR
DON'T WORK. FOR CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE OUGHT TO TAKE THAT
MONEY MAYBE WE ARE PUT INTO
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME OR SOME
OTHER- AVENUE WHICH WHICH WE
CAN REALLY HELP PEOPLE. HAVE A
MORE AFFORDABLE BETTER QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
AS IT IS- YEAH WHAT WHAT WHAT
WE TALK ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AT TWO AND THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
DOOR. MOST STATES IN THIS
NATION WITH YOU KNOW THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS BUDGET
PRETTY NICE HOUSE. RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIANS OVER CITIES IT
MIGHT BUY YOU. A STUDIO
AFFORDABLE APARTMENT RIGHT.
THAT'S INSANE AND IT'S GOT TO
STOP AT SOME POINT IT'S GOT TO
STOP BY OUR URBAN. LEGISLATORS
OF WHICH YOU'RE PART OF THAT
DELEGATION RIGHT- COMING TO
GRIPS WITH NOT JUST PUSHING ALL
THEIR PROBLEMS ON EVERYBODY
ELSE. AND THEN ASKING FOR
SUBSIDY BUT ATHER LOOK AT IT
REAL REFORM AND A REAL
EVALUATION OF HOW DO WE SPEND
OUR TAX DOLLARS- IN A MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY AND MAYBE YOU
HAVE AN IDEA THAT'S WORTH.
PURSUING BUT- I'D LIKE YOUR
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE PURSUING
THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF BEING
WILLING TO REALLY. TACKLE TOUGH
ISSUES AND NOT JUST- YOU KNOW
NOT JUST HAVE HASHTAGS ABOUT
TOUGH ISSUES WHICH IS WHAT I
FIND WITH TOO MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES SO. I WITH THAT
CRIMINAL TO CONSIDER-
SUPPORTING THIS AGO MILITIA THE
REST OF DEBATE BUT. I DO HAVE
SOME MAJOR CONCERNS OR- MISTER
LEVINE AND THEN- MISS. OF JEWS
AGREES. TO DO YOU WANT TO BE
CALLED. OKAY EVERYONE WE HAVE
THREE MORE BILLS TO GET THROUGH
IN ONE HOUR I JUST WANNA PUT
THAT ON EVERYONE'S RADAR. MR
LEVINE AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YEAH THIS IS A FAT FASTENING
CONVERSATIONS SO I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR AUTHORING THE BILL
IN AND ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFULNESS. ON THIS
AND I I'VE WRESTLED WITH- YOU
KNOW WITH WHAT IS A SAFETY NET
AND WHAT THE PEOPLE NEED TO
ECONOMICALLY SURVIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AUTHORED TWO BILLS
TO. TIE A MINIMUM WAGE THE COST
OF HOUSING IN IN CALCANEUS
WHERE PEOPLE WORK- THAT HAVE
DIED IN APPROPRIATIONS WHERE I
EXPECT THIS BILL TO DIE- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
IT. BUT IT'S MY BIRTHDAY TODAY
AND ONLY GIVE OUT A PRESENT
WHICH IS I'M GONNA SUPPORT A
BILL. SO VERY VERY GENEROUS ON
MY BIRTHDAY. IS THIS IS YOU
KNOW I'M NOT A TRUE BELIEVER IN
U. B. I. BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS YOU KNOW I'M I'M LEARNING
ABOUT IT. AND WE'RE SEEING
DIFFERENT EXPERIMENTS WHICH I
THINK IS A REALLY GOOD THING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IT IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES AND SO- YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S VERY EARLY ON
BECAUSE WE'RE JUST SEEN A YOU
KNOW A GROWING OF THOSE
EXPERIMENTS AROUND THE STATE SO
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN ONE OR TWO
BUT WE NEED TO SEE MANY MANY
MORE. TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
RIGHT AS WELL AS WHAT'S RIGHT
IN SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES AND
WHAT WHAT HELPS PEOPLE. ON IN
EACH COMMUNITY MY CONCERN ABOUT
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS GOING WILD
WITH SO WHAT WERE THEY WANT
THEY WANT TO. GET AN EDUCATION
THEY WANT TO. YOU KNOW GET GET
A CAR TO GET TO WORK ON MAYBE
GET SOME HOUSING THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE WANT BASICALLY- IN
MARIN. THEY'RE DOING ONE BASED
ON LOW INCOME MOTHERS OF COLOR.
AND I'M REALLY FASCINATED BY
THIS THEY'RE GONNA CHOOSE A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE. A LOT MORE
QUALIFY AND THEIR BASE SEEN WHO
CAN QUALIFY OFF OF WHAT'S
CALLED THE SELF SUFFICIENCY
STANDARD. DEVELOPED BY THE
INSTITUTE CENTER FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN OAKLAND THE SELF
SUFFICIENCY STANDARD FOR A
FAMILY OF FOUR WITH TWO
CHILDREN. IN MARIN IS A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
PLACE- SO WITH THIS EXPERIMENT
THAT THEY'RE HAVING THAT THE-
DATA SAID THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO PARTICIPATE. YEAH
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
GET SOME HEALTHY FOOD INTO
THEIR CHILDREN'S YOU KNOW TIME
IS. A SAFE PLACE FOR THEM TO
LIVE- REALLY SOME BASIC THINGS
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL ALSO CREATE
A SAFETY NET FOR THEM BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
COSTS THAT COME OUT. FOR
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN. SO I'M
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THESE
DIFFERENT EXPERIMENTS POP UP
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO INFORM.
BILLS LIKE YOURS I THINK SELECT
COMMITTEE IS A GREAT WAY. TO
FURTHER EXPLORE PROBABLY A
LITTLE EARLY TO CREATE. A
STATEWIDE ELIGIBILITY. BECAUSE
I JUST DON'T KNOW. IF THAT'S IF
THAT IS THE RIGHT APPROACH BUT
AGAIN I DON'T THINK WERE FULLY
INFORMED YET BUT LET'S MOVE
THIS ALONG TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. RATHER THAN-
CLOSE THE DOOR ON IT THANK YOU.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY THANK YOU.
ISRAEL THIS. THANK YOU- YOU
KNOW I'VE STRUGGLED WITH THE
CONCEPT OF A UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME- I BELIEVE EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE A UNIVERSAL BASIC
BUT I FEEL THAT- IT SHOULD BE
THROUGH A GOOD JOB RATE AND WE
WANT TO WORK YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT A LOW INCOME
DISTRICT- WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO
DRIVE HOURS TO GET TO WORK. TO
GET A GOOD PAYING JOB- AND- AND
BECAUSE OF THAT I KNOW THAT-
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS COULD
BENEFIT A LOT OF FAMILIES BUT-
I STILL THINK THAT A GOOD JOB
IS WHAT. WE NEED TO BE
PROVIDING I KNOW THAT TAKES A
LOT LONGER- AND- EVEN THOUGH AT
I AM CONCERNED THAT THERE ISN'T
A FUNDING SOURCE- AND SOME OF
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP IN THE ANALYSES- BUT
I DO PLAN TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
TODAY TO KEEP THE CONVERSATION
GOING ON I KNOW THIS ISN'T A
ONE YEAR. BILL RIGHT THIS IS A
POTENTIALLY MULTIPLE YEARS.
ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW I COMMEND
YOU FOR STARTING THIS
CONVERSATION- FOR OUR STATE SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
I BELIEVE THE INTENTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. TO BE LAUDABLE AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT'S SOMETHING THAT A
LOT OF FOLKS DON'T UNDERSTAND.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT THERE'S
NOT REALLY A LOT OF DATA OUT
THERE. THAT WE CAN TURN TO I
THERE ARE SOME BAY AREA CITIES
THAT HAVE STARTED VERY NEW
PROGRAM STOCKTON I KNOW HAS THE
PROGRAM GOING. AND A REPORT HAS
JUST COME OUT RECENTLY BUT IT
ONLY INCLUDES ONE YEAR'S WORTH
OF DATA. SO JUST REAL QUICK I
KNOW WE HAVE A OTHER BILLS TO
HEAR- TO THE QUESTION A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHORS HOW
IMPORTANT. IS IT TO THE
CONVERSATION THAT THIS BILL
LEASES. GETS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND HAVE A GRAYSON.
ABSOLUTELY I I'M NOT TRYING TO.
MAKE ANY TYPE OF. A STATEMENT
THAT THIS IS FULLY COOKED. IN
FACT I SAID IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS THAT. THE PRICE TAG
WHICH STREET BECAUSE IT WAS.
THIS IS NOT A FEASIBLE SOLUTION
BUT LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE HAVING
DIALOGUE ABOUT THE POLICY OF
BASIC INCOME. AND BY THE WAY
WE'RE SEEING MANY ITERATIONS OF
THIS IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND WHY BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
HURTING EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS
ARE HURTING IS THIS GOING TO BE
THE SILVER BULLET NOT
NECESSARILY OUR JOBS OF WHERE
TO GO ABSOLUTELY. BUT WE ARE
HAVING A DIALOGUE AND TO ALLOW
FOR THE PUBLIC PROCESS. TO ALSO
CURSED SUCHTHAT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN ALSO SEE AND HEAR
ABOUT THE POLICY CONVERSATION.
THAT WE CANNOT JUST GO OUT AND
MAKE THE STATEMENTS THAT YES
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY GOING TO
SOLVE ONE PROBLEM. AND WILL
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT RATHER LOOK
THIS IS WE ARE WE ARE
DELIBERATE OF BODY AND HAVING
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS ABOUT.
HOW THIS CAN ACTUALLY BE DONE
HOW THE IMPLEMENTATION WITH
IMPLICATION LOOK AT ONE OF THE
DISTINCTIONS BEHALF WHICH FIND
IT. AND HOW DOES THIS ADD UP
GOING TO AFFECT IN COMPARISON
TO SOME OTHER EXISTING PROGRAMS
HAVE TO STRING SOME OTHER
PROGRAMS OR NOT. AND THAT'S
WHAT I WELCOME THE DIALOGUE
THAT WE'RE HAVING TODAY SHOULD
THIS MOVE FORWARD AND THAT IS
MY REQUEST. TO BE EQUALLY
COMMITTED TO AS AN AUTHOR TO
SAY THAT SHOULD THIS LEAVE THE
COMMUNITY I'M ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED. TO WORKING. OUT
THESE ISSUES AS IT MOVES TOWARD.
I'M GONNA TAKE THAT ARE CLOSE.
BUT THEY DID JUST FINALLY. OKAY
ONCE AGAIN THOUGH I WILL SAY
THIS I DO AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION I'M WE DO SEE
PILOTS PROGRAMS GOING ON AND I
THINK ALL WITH A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY ONCE IN THIS
CLEARLY IS NOT A ONE YOUR BILL
THERE'S A HUGE CONVERSATION IN
THE AUTHOR IS VERY WELL AWARE
THAT. IS WHY WE TOOK THE
FINDING OUT BUT IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION NEVER THE LESS- I
DON'T FEEL LIKE THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS THAT SOMEONE JUST
CHECKED INTO TO KIND OF GET
THEIR PRESS RELEASE I ACTUALLY
FEEL LIKE THIS WAS A NEEDED
CONVERSATION WILL CONTINUE TO
BE A CONVERSATION AS ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT PILOT PROGRAMS
GOING THROUGH THE STATE AND
THROUGH THE COUNTRY WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COOK YES AND
JUST VERY QUICKLY MADAM CHAIR.
IT'S BIG IT'S BECAUSE OF THAT
ISSUE THAT WE'VE SEEN MANY
CITIES. HAVE SIMILAR DURATIONS
INTRODUCTION OF THIS AS WELL AS
I INTRODUCED THIS LAST YEAR
COVERED WE IT WAS HELD I
REQUEST TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THIS TO ACTUALLY IRON OUT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON SOME OF THE V.
SO I'M DEEPLY COMMITTED THIS IS
NOT JUST GRANDSTANDING THIS IS
TO HAVE A DELIBERATE OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE POLICY
AND HOW THAT. M. FACTORS INTO
HELPING AT PROTECT EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIA'S WITH RESPECT AS
FOR ADULT WOMEN TIME WHEN YOU
CALL THE ROLL. SHE I. GREATLY
OUT I'LL SECOND. FINE. RUSSIAN
SB NATION- I- NOT WE ARE NOT
GOING. RIGHT I. BEING YEAH THEY-
THREE THREE LOWLAND ASIAN
MARKETS. FOUR HOURS OF WORK HI
WORK. THIS TIME RIVAS YEAH NO.
WELL FIVE OF THEM AND- THEY'RE
BUILT ON CALL THANK YOU I'M A
SELLER WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PREVENT YOUR BILL WE HAVE THREE
BILLS AGAIN MEMBERS WE HAVE
THREE BILLS LEFT TO GET DONE IN
FORTY FIVE MINUTES. WE ARE.
LOOKING FOR BREVITY. THE BILL.
THANKS EVERYONE OF NO OKAY.
THANK YOU- MANAGER THIS IS A
DECIDEDLY MORE BORING TECHNICAL
SCHOOL TRIED TO MAKE IT AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE- FOR SO I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF- I WILL ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS RETURNING
TO THE TIME FRAME AS TO WHEN A
CITY OR NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
CAN PURCHASE A TAX DEFAULT
PROPERTY FROM THREE YEARS BACK
TO FIVE YEARS THESE ELEMENTS
ADDRESS A MAJOR CONCERN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA REALTORS ASSOCIATION
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING OUT
THE REMAINING CONCERNS WITH CAR
BEFORE THE BILL IS VOTED ON ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. ADDRESSING
THEIR REMAINING CONCERNS WILL
BRING THEM TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION WHICH I AM EAGER TO
GET TO. AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
SIX TO ENHANCE AND STRENGTHEN
EXISTING CHAPTER EIGHT PROCESS
FOR ACQUIRING IT AND WE HAVING
TAX DELINQUENT HOMES. OUR FOCUS
IS TO REMOVE ABANDONED BLIGHTED
PROPERTIES FROM NEIGHBORHOODS
TO GIVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD IN WORKPLACES. AND REMOVE%
TAX ILLEGAL PROPERTIES FROM THE
CITY THE EARTH THEY COUNTY
LEDGER. ALL THE WHILE KEEPING
EXISTING TENANTS HOUSED IN
INCREASING HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS. IN OAKLAND THERE
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND SEVENTY ONE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN ANY
GIVEN NIGHT. AND THREE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED TEN OF WHOM ARE
UNSHELTERED. THE LACK OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN THE BAY
AREA HUSBAND HAS PUT TREMENDOUS
PRESSURE ON ON OAKLAND'S
HOUSING MARKET. WAGES FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR REMAIN STAGNANT
THIS AND AS THE CITY BECOMES
MORE GENTRIFIED INCREASING THE
RISK OF EVICTION AND HOUSING
AND SECURITY. IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT OUR REGION AND STATE CAN
FIND CREATIVE WAYS TO BUILD AND
PRESERVATIVES OR HOUSING.
EXISTING LAW EXISTING LAWS
GIVES NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES THE FIRST OPTION TO
PURCHASE TAX DEFAULTED
PROPERTIES. THREE YEARS AFTER
TAX DELINQUENCY TO THE CHAPTER
EIGHT TAX DEFAULT PROPERTY
SALE. THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS THE
ABILITY TO ACQUIRE VACANT AND
BLIGHTED SITES. OFTEN A CHEAPER
PRICE TO TRANSFORM THEM INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ONLY FIFTY
FIVE PROPERTIES HAVE BEEN SOLD
THROUGH CHAPTER A PROCESS FOR
WILL HOUSING PURPOSES OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS FIFTY FIVE IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS. THIS DATA
POINT PROVES THAT THE PROCESS
IS UNDER UTILIZED. AND
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
NEEDS. AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT SIX
TO DO THAT- AND I ALSO WANT TO
SAY MY STUFF AND COSPONSORS ARE
IN CLOSE COMMUNICATION WITH THE
TAX COLLECTOR. TAX TAX
COLLECTORS ASSOCIATION. THE
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S ASSOCIATION
AND OTHER RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS
WITH THE HOPES OF ADDRESSING
THEIR CONCERNS AS WE MOVE THE
BALL FORWARD. AND I PERSONALLY
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THEM AND KEEPING THE
DIALOGUE OPEN. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OUR- OUR
NICOLO DELUCA WHO'S
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
OAKLAND. VESTED IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PEDRO DELGADO WITH
NONPROFIT HOUSING. TIME WITH
THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESSES
INTO THE PRIMARY WITNESSES WE
DO HAVE A- WE HAVE TO BILL WAS
LEFT AND WE- HAVE A MOST. AND A
ALREADY WE WITH SO WE CAN GO
CORPORATE. THANK YOU. REMEMBER
BURKE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICCOLO TELECARE
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF OAKLAND
WHEN THE CO SPONSORS WANT TO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE STAFF. I LOVE
BREVITY. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT WHEN DRAFTING
THIS BILL TO THE CITY OF
OAKLAND AND THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
TAX COLLECTOR DONE A PILOT
PROGRAM Sí
BILL. A LOT OF THE ITEMS THAT
THEY ENCOUNTERED WE PUT INTO
THIS BILL WE ALSO WANT TO
PROVIDE MAXIMUM FLOW
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THAT'S WHY THE
BILL USES IMAGE SUCH AS MAY AS
OPPOSED TO SHALL. AND IN
ADDITION WE ARE NOT ASKING TO
WAIVE FEES OR ANYTHING OF THAT
NATURE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CLEARLY
SAID OAKLAND AND OTHER CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT HAD.
A MASSIVE HOMELESS PROBLEM
WE'VE GOT A BALLOT ABANDONED
HOUSES THAT WERE TRYING TO PUT
INTO PRODUCTIVE USE GET BACK ON
THE COUNTY LEDGER. PROTECT
TENANTS AND IMPROVE CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOODS SO INCLUDING
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WHICH BE WILLING TO
THIS. SECOND AND. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAU PARKING BY SEAN
MORAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME
THE TITLE GONZALEZ I'M POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OUR MISSION IS TO
FIGHT FOR A BAY AREA WHERE
EVERYONE HAS AN AFFORDABLE AND
STABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
IN OUR STATE AND I NEED CALL
ONE POINT TWO MILLION NEW
AFFORDABLE HOMES CALIFORNIA
DESPERATELY NEEDS TO BUILD AND
PRESERVE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. OUR ORGANIZATION AND
PH'S COSPONSORING EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE IT WILL
HELP CONVERT HOMES THAT HAVE
PROBLEMS TAX WILL INCREASE THE
INTO PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PROTECTING TENANTS
FROM DISPLACEMENT. JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS
BUT THE BILL DIED- IT WILL HELP
TENANTS WHO RAISED AND
TAXONOMICAL PROPERTY BECOME
HOMEOWNERS BY GIVING THEM A
LIKE TO PURCHASE THIS PROPERTY
BEFORE THEY BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR
TAX BILL IF THE TENANT DOESN'T
HAVE THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
PURCHASE THE PROPERTY IT GIVES
THEM A RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL
TO BE DEVELOPED PROPERTY AT A
RENTAL OR SALES PRICES
AFFORDABLE TO BATON. AT THEIR
INCOME LEVEL. IT WILL ALSO
INCREASE THE USE OF THE CHAPTER
EIGHT PROCESS TO CREATE MORE
PORTABLE HOMES BY CREATING A
MORE PREDICTABLE PROCESS TO
CONVERT TECHNICAL PROPERTY INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REQUIRING
THE CREATION OF EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES AND A STANDARDIZED
PROCESS. AND GIVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MORE FLEXIBILITY-
THAT THEY NEED TO MOVE THESE
PROPERTIES PROPERTY THROUGH THE
PROCESS. AND SO- BY MOVING
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY CORD YOU
WILL BE HOPING TO ENSURE THE
LONG TERM NEIGHBORHOOD
AFFORDABILITY AND STABILITY-
FOR DECADES TO COME AND SO
WITH- FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I THOUGHT
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE-
OPEN FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME.
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE. THANK
YOU IF YOU TO SPEAK AND SO. OF
AB FIVE TO EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
THE AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT NINE IN Q.
FOUR TO ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
JENNIFER TECH ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS I KNOW I'M OUT OF
ORDER BUT I WANTED TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE THE MEMBER AND HER
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ALONG
WITH THE SPONSORS TO RESOLVE
THE MAJORITY OF OUR CONCERNS
BEFORE THE BILL LEAVE OF THE
COMMITTEE AND WE FULLY EXPECT.
TO BE NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE'S
INCIDENT BEFORE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE
MATTER THAT LAND PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS NUMBER FROM
ALSO WE HAVE A PUBLICADVOCATE
SO WE SAID IN OUR LETTER LATE-
BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THINK. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JAY BANFIELD FROM ALL
HOME AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FIVE TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHAEL IN WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANE URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION HONEST
BURKE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I'M SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BOBBY LOOK IS ON
BEHALF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THE
PUBLIC WHEN INVESTING ON BEHALF
OF GENERATION HOUSING AND
ASSEMBLY GET PRETENDING STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI KATIE LAMONT WITH TENDERLOIN
NEIGHBORHOOD DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AS OF YET
ON BEHALF OF THE PORTABLE
FASTER CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WAS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
CENTER. SEEING NINE ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE OF-
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR THE OPPOSITION
PLEASE KAREN LANG OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBER
EIGHT THREE SHAPE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUFFICIENT COUNTY TREASURERS
AND TAX COLLECTORS. THE FIRST I
JUST WANTED TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR MAKING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING A PRIORITY IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NO JOY. I TO BE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO YOUR BILL. AND
SECONDLY I WANTED TO THANK YOUR
STAFF THEY- TOOK A LOT OF TIME
WITH ME TO TALK THROUGH THE
CONFINES THAT ARE- MY CLIENT
HAD WITH YOUR BILL. AND HE DID
A GREAT JOB IN THE ANALYSES.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL KEY
POINTS IN THE BILL OF THAT-
BROUGHT OUT THE OPPOSITION OF
MY CLIENT. THE ACCELERATION OF
THE TIME LINE WITH ONE OF THEM
SO THANK YOU FOR RESTORING
THAT. BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROBLEMS THAT REMAIN IN THE
BILL THAT- CREATE HUGE CONCERNS
FOR THE. TAX COLLECTORS- TOP OF
THE LINE. WHEN EVER ATTACK
ATTORNEY PUT HOME ON A ON A TAX
SALE THE FINAL SEVEN THAT AFTER
MANY CERTIFIED MAILINGS IS TO
VISIT THE PROPERTY AND MAKE
CONTACT WITH THE OWNER AND THE
OWNER SLASH TENANT AND OFTEN
TIMES WHEN THEY GET THERE
THERE'S A LOT MORE HAPPENING AT
THE PROPERTY BEYOND I'M NOT
PAYING THEIR TAXES AND A LOT OF
TIMES THAT'S LAST BUILDINGS
THEY PAY. OR THEY THOUGHT PAINT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANNA LOSE
THEIR HOME AND SOMEONE HOME
THAT THEIR LARGEST ASSET SO
SOMETIMES THERE'S SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT ARE BROUGHT IN
ENOUGH OF FAIRLY COMMON.
OCCURRENCE IT'S NOT THAT I. YOU
KNOW THEY JUST GO THERE AND
TELL THEM WE'RE GOING TO PUT ON
A TAX AMNESTY AND THE IS
HAPPENING OVER FIVE. THEIR
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
GET SERVICES IS TO KEEP PEOPLE
ON THEIR HOME GET FAMILIES
INVOLVED- BECAUSE MAYBE FAMILY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THAT
AFFECTS- THE- THE PERSON WHO
OWNS THE PROPERTY. DOT DOT
CONCERN IS HUGE FOR US-
SECONDLY CREATING AND PRESSURE
THE BILL DOES CREATE PRESSURE
TO REDUCE THE MINIMUM. AND FOR
THE BENEFIT OF NUMBERS TEN MORE
SECONDS- ONCE USED. OKAY WELL.
THE MINIMUM BID WE WILL TAKE
AWAY. WHICH OPERATE IF THEY'RE
TAKING MONEY AWAY FROM SCHOOLS
ALL THE TECHNICAL NEWS. I WHEN
YOU DO THAT AND HE ALSO LEAVES
A PERSON ON THE PROPERTY WITH.
NOTHING THEY WALK AWAY WITH
NOTHING EVEN ABOUT WHAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN THEIR BIGGEST ASSET.
BUT ALSO CREATE WAIT A COUPLE
NEW DUTIES ON TAX COLLECTORS
AND HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE IF YOU HEARD OF SOMEONE
ACTUALLY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE YOUR HOME MAY I KNOW
I'M THINKING. THERE'S A LOT
THERE'S A LOT OF HERE AND I
FOUND THAT THE RULES ARE THE
SAME FOR EVERYBODY IT'S TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH SPORT AND EACH
OPPOSITION SO. GIVE ME FIVE
SECONDS TO TIE IT UP PLEASE. SO
WE'RE- WE ARE ASKING. THAT THE-
COMMITTEE HOLD THE BILL HERE
BILL BECAUSE- OF AN OF THE
THIRD. WE THINK WILL BE AN WE
ASKED IT I KNOW FOR FREE TO
HOLD. THANK YOU THINK YOU AND
WHEN THE MODERATE. OKAY THE-
FOR ADDITIONAL. AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU YOU WISH TO SPEAK IT
OUT. OF AB FIVE TO EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
COMMENTING Q. I'M SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
STARR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME STUDENT THANK YOU-
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCING CENTER.
FROM SOME ANGLES. ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THAT ALL RIGHT
I'M TO COME TO QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. SAYING THAT THE
STATE IS NONE IF WE- AREN'T
REALLY QUICKLY I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE FEEL
FOR IT HOWEVER I DO HAVE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS AS THE
OPPOSITION- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
IT'S IMPORTANT CONSERVE OUR
RIGHTS TO PROPERTY OWNERS AND
THIS USUALLY IS THEIR LARGEST
ASSET. AND ANY KIND POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH THAT SO I
UNDERSTAND YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE MOMENTS AND
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO WE DO. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A GRAY. BUT THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE FAN
MAY A HIGHLY COLOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS A MAY TO. FOR I
BURKE BY WHEN. WHEN NO GREAT.
GRAYSON I'VE RECENTLY. LIVING
WE ARE MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
ON. MULLIN I KNOW. JURORS ARE
QUIRK HI I RIVAS RIVAS I'D SAY
ARE TO KNOW THEY ARE TO KNOW.
SIX THE VOTERS SEVENTY TWO THE
BILL HAS PASSED BALBOA CAPITAL
IS OUT TALKING PARK WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL FOLKS
WE'VE GOT TWO BILLS LEFT TO GET
DONE IN THIRTY MINUTES WE CAN
DO IT. THE BILL. I'M A BELIEVER.
SO THIS BILL IS ABOUT ASKING
ESSENTIALLY- SOME PROFESSORS AT
UC TO TAKE A LOOK. AT CORPORATE
TAX BREAKS COME U WITH HOW
MUCH THE COST IN THE STATE.
WHAT'S DONE IN OTHER STATES
AND- WHAT WE FEEL IS GAINED BY
HAVING THESE DEDUCTIONS. I IN
MONETARILY THERE WILL BE NO
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE AS TO
WHETHER SHOULD BE CONTINUED OR
NOT CONTINUED- WE WILL TAKE THE
ADVICE OF THE COMMITTEE AND
KNOCKED OUT TAKE A LOOK AT. S.
CHAPTER- TAXES BECAUSE IT'S IN
CONFORMITY WITH THE FEDS AND
CONFORMITY IS ALWAYS TO BE-
FIVE A GOAL IS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED WITH THAT TAX POLICY
HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED IT- WILL
ALSO- TAKE THEIR ADVICE ON. ON
THE DUE DATE- WHICH IS WE'VE
GOT TO WITH THEM THERE IT'LL
PROBABLY BE THE LATER DATE-
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
UNLESS YOU SEE SAYS- WE'D LOVE
TO GET OUT OF WAY EARLY-
ANYTHING ELSE. NOPE THAT'S IT
THANK YOU GREAT WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
LINE. OR ON THE LINE. BONTA
READER IF YOU COULD A BOOK AND
I JUST WITH KATIE HARTMAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
I THINK HE IS A CO SPONSOR OF
THE SELLING ONE I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORPORATE WORK
AND HE DID A GREAT JOB IN ITS
OPENING THOUGHT IT OUT A COUPLE
OF POINTS- ONE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE YOU KNOW HAD
REPORTED OF ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
EXPENDITURES- IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THAT
NUMBER CONTINUES TO GROW
OBVIOUSLY THAT HAS A HUGE
IMPACT ON THE STATE BUDGET-
WITH YOU KNOW 40% OF THE BUDGET
DEDICATED TO EDUCATION THAT
MEANS ABOUT THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS RE DIRECTED AWAY FROM
CLASSROOMS IN THE FORM OF TAX
EXPENDITURES EACH YEAR- WHICH
IS WHY WE BELIEVE MORE
TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT IF
NECESSARY- THIS BILL IS NOT
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE ANY. AND
EXISTING TAX EXPENDITURES THAT
WATER AND WE PROVIDE THE STATE
WITH MORE INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE IF THEY ARE
ACCOMPLISHING THE INTENDED
GOALS- SO AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES PROVIDE AN ANNUAL
TAX EXPENDITURE REPORT BUT
THERE'S ONLY PROVIDE SORT OF A
MINIMAL MINIMAL INFORMATION-
AND THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE A
DEEPER TAX DIED ON SOME OF
THOSE TAX EXPENDITURES-
INCLUDING COMPARISON WITH
OTHERS HE- WHAT THE ECONOMIC
SOCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT ARE
SO. AND THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
THE NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AND AYE
URGENT AYE VOEPEL THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH CHRISTY
BOMB OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS- WE
DO HAVE TO BILLS LEFT TO GET
DONE IN THIRTY MINUTES. OR
REQUESTING PROPERTY PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR A- THANK MADAM
CHAIR AS YOU WISH I CRISTINA ON
THE OF THE K. PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FORTY FIVE. IT'S
BEEN STATED WHAT IT'S WHAT THE
BILL DOES I WOULD JUST SAY THE
ONE GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
MOST COSTLY SENATORS ARE
CHEATING THEIR INTENDED PUBLIC
POLICY OBJECTIVES. AND
COMMITTEES CHAIRED BY YOURSELF
CERTAINLY WOULD BE GUIDED BY
THE RESULTS OF THIS STUDY THAT
YOU ARE. CONSIDERING POLICY
INTERESTS FOR GRANTING TARGET
RELIEF OR INCENTIVES FOR
CERTAIN BEHAVIORS OF THESE.
ANOTHER HAVE BEEN MADE THEIR
SIGNIFICANT SOMETIMES MADE
WITHOUT FULL FULL UNDERSTANDING
THE BETA THE IMPACT OF THOSE.
TAX CREDITS ON THE GENERAL FUND
AND AS YOU KNOW AN APARTMENT
PARTY MENTIONED EVERY DOLLAR
THE GENERAL FUND AND THEN THE
POCKETS OF SCHOOLS FIRE PUBLIC
SAFETY- AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FACE MASSIVE AND
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN THE
NEAR TERM. HIGHLIGHTING THE
NEED TO PROTECT CRUCIAL
REVENUES TO FUND THE FIREFIGHT
SO- TRANSPARENCY THE CAVALIER
SENTUL TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S STATING ITS RETURN
ON INVESTMENTS. THESE ARE THE
RESULTS WERE STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WHICH NOW OPEN THE
LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FOUR FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FOUR LINES INTO A
WORLDWIDE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN MY MAGENTO BUT ISN'T
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR OFFICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CORPORATE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
I'M A CO SPONSOR THANK YOU
THINK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOWNLOAD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M AT
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MARTHA ALBERT AVAILABLE
TO HELP US IN A PRACTICAL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
READ TO HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY FOR SUPPORT AND SUPPORT
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
CENTER. NO ANY IN THE HEARING
ROOM NO THE MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE NO THE MAILING FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WORLDWIDE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOT PLASTER COUNTY AND
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME GREDDY
COMPLIMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER GREG.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIRMAN
LICCARDO NOT UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BETTER KIND OF WHAT YOUR
GOALS ARE AND THE- THE BREATH
OF THE POLICY HERE RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE LOOKING AT TAX
EXPENDITURES- THINGS LIKE I
ASSUME THE HOLLYWOOD TAX CREDIT
THE TRACTOR TO ACTUALLY NOT THE
HOLLYWOOD TAX CREDIT ANYTHING
THAT HAS TO SUNSET ON IT. WE'RE
NOT LOOKING AT IT WE'RE SIMPLY
LOOKING AT THE ONES THAT WERE
DONE PRIOR TO ASKING FOR SUNSET
THAT ARE THEIR PERPETUALLY AND-
I LOOK AT THIS BILL SHOULD
SOMEONE COME UP. WITH A
PROPOSAL TO CUT ANY OF THOSE-
THAT THEY WERE I HOPE THEY
WOULD WAIT. UNTIL WE GET THIS
FULL REPORT ON THE- CORPORATE
TAX BREAKS TO DO NOT HAVE
SUNSETS BUT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT THAT WAS TEN
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING
THAT AS CORPORATION.
CONSIDERATION IS PROBABLY NINE
NOW. AND ARE WE LOOKING ALSO
AT- X. POLICY MORE GENERALLY
LIKE- NO IT STARTED AT LEVI'S
DI<c.cyan> AND ESSENTIALLY THE-</c>
WHAT THEY'LL SAY IS HERE'S WHAT
ACROSS THE STATE. THESE ARE THE
BENEFITS- LEGISLATURE YOU
DECIDE WHAT YOU WANT TO DO NEXT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT'S GOING
TO COME UP WITH. SO IF I WERE
TO SAY TO YOU THAT THAT THAT
THAT STRIKES ME AS IT'S MAYBE
DUPLICATIVE OF THE WORK WE DO
HERE. IN THIS COMMITTEE NO
BECAUSE OUR CHARGE WE ARE
YOU'RE NOT LOOKED. AT IN DETAIL
ABOUT WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE OF
THESE PROGRAMS WE CLEARLY HAVE
THE NUMBERS ON WHAT THE COST IS
WHAT THE STATE SPENDING ON THEM
WELL WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT THE
BENEFITS ARE. AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. AND WE DON'T KNOW
THAT BECAUSE- WE HAVE A WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND THE-
WELL FOLKS THAT WE WORK THERE
AND RIGHT WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
IS GOING TO TAKE TIME AND
ENERGY AND- I DON'T THINK THAT
THE STAFF HERE HAS THE BAND
WITH TO DO IT. WE DID TALK TO
THE L. A. O. ONE TIME ABOUT
HAVING THEM DO IT THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR IT- BUT
THE REASON WE TAKEN OUT. THOSE
WITH THE CENTS A DAY AND THOSE
WITH METRICS IS BECAUSE- THERE
WAS A BILL AT. EVENTUALLY THAT
SAID THAT ALL POLICY THAT CAME
THROUGH- ALL EXPENDITURES THAT
CAME THERE HAD TO HAVE EIGHT.
HAVE TO HAVE METRICS INCLUDED
IN THERE OR THEY COULD BE
PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE WHICH A
LOT OF PEOPLE COMPLAIN ABOUT
ACTUALLY WHEN THEY COME TO
COMMITTEE. SO ANYTHING THAT'S
PASSED THAT HAS ALL THOSE
METRICS RIGHT. WE ARE WE
REQUIRE THAT THOSE METRICS BE
PART OF THE BILL. AS IT PASSES.
THESE ARE SOME BILLS THAT
WARRANT DID NOT HAVE SENT THAT
DAY OR METRIC REQUIREMENTS. AND
SO THESE ARE BUT A LAYERS. AND
MEASURE ALL ALONG THAT LINE OF
THINKING THAT WHY DON'T WE JUST
INSERT SUNSET DATE SUNDAY.
EVERY TAX POLICY WE DO NOT
ACTUALLY AT THAT WE DON'T KNOW
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE IT
WE- WE HAVE THE- GUYS TO DO
THAT TODAY WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
YEAH WE DON'T. IF THAT'S I WANT
TO BRING UP EACH ONE OF THOSE
BILLS BUT SO. BUT IN ATHENS
THIS WAS A WAY OF ACTUALLY
GETTING A STUDY TO EVALUATE ALL
OF THOSE THAT ALL OF THE
ACTUAL. HOW IF THESE CUT BUT
THE EFFICACY OF ART OF THE TAX
CREDITS. BECAUSE WE DID NOT
REQUIRE IT BEFORE. SO IT JUST
IT GIVES ME PAUSE I MEAN THAT'S
NOT THE WAY TO SKIN A CAT. I
THINK IT IT LEADS US IN THE
DIRECTION WELL. HEY IT'S
SUGGESTS TO OUR CONSTITUENCIES
AND EVEN WITHIN. OUR OWN
INSTITUTION HERE- WHICH WORKED
AT. THAT THERE'S A RIGHT ANSWER
RIGHT RATHER THAN. I WOULD MAKE
AN ARGUMENT THAT I ATTACHED
POLICIES REALLY MATTER TRADE
OFFS RIGHT- WHAT. ONE
SUBCENTRAL CALIFORNIA'S MATE
MAY DO WELL UNDER SOMETHING
WHILE ANOTHER SUFFERS OR VICE
VERSA- AND IT JUST GIVES ME A
LITTLE BIT OF RESERVATION. THAT
WE TRY TO OUT SOURCE OUR WORK
HERE THE EGISLATURE- IT IN IN
THE PURSUIT OF. AND BY NO MEANS
LIMIT LET MEGO AHEAD SAY I
AGREE WITH YOU. MORE
INFORMATION IS BETTER THAT THE
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO ARGUMENT
THAT WE SHOULDN'T. AVAIL
OURSELVES OF THOSE RESOURCES I
JUST DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY
WE NEED A BILL TO DO SO I GUESS.
WELL WE DO BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE BANDWIDTH AND FRANKLY.
THIS WOULD BE AN INDEPENDENT.
VALUATION YOU DON'T WANT THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH MIGHT NEED
TAXES MAKING THIS EVALUATION.
IN FAIRNESS WE DO HAVE LOTS OF
ELSE OFFICE THE WE HAVE THE
STATE AUDITOR DAVE GRAHAM THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY WE ASK
THEM LAST YEAR. WILL WE CAN
INCREASE THEIR BUDGET INCREASE
THE CAPACITY I'M JUST TELLING
YOU WE DID GO TO THEM AND THEY
DID NOT THE CAPACITY AND THE
BUDGET FOR THEM TO DO IT WAS
LARGER THAN THIS WAS ACTUALLY
THE THIS WAS AN EFFICIENT WAY
TO COLLECT THAT INFORMATION.
AND BE. OSZYCE WHAT ARE DOLLARS.
I AM STILL HAVE AN OBJECTIVE
OPINION ANALYSIS. FOR THOSE
THINGS THAT ARE NOT BEING WE'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO HAVE AN
ANALYSIS ORIGINALLY IS NOT AND
IF WE WERE TO ASK ONE OF THOSE
GROUPS TO DO IT SINCE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE THEY
WOULD HAVE TO FARM IT OUT AS
WELL YOU DON'T WANT TO HIRE A
BUNCH TAX EXPERTS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO USE ONCE. SO EITHER
WAY YOU'RE LIKELY TO THIS WAY
IT'S TRANSPARENT WE KNOW WHO'S
GOING TO DO IT IT'S A
PARTICULAR BRANCH IF YOU SEE. I
APPRECIATE THE- THE EXPLANATION
AND ARE YOU. OPEN TO OUR
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS POLICY
TO OPEN IT UP TO. A BROADER
ARRAY OF TAX POLICY INCLUDING-
YOU KNOW HOW WE EVALUATE OUR
TAX SYSTEM YOU MIGHT BE
INTERESTED TO SEE YOU KNOW
WHAT- WHY NOT RELAYING THE
TAXES IF THOSE ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE. PLACES TO YEAH WE
CAN LOOK AT A NEW BILL NEXT
YEAR I'M RIGHT NOW WITH
LIMITED-HEARINGS I'M GOING TO
KEEP THIS BILL IS NARROW AS IT
IS. BUT WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
FOR NEXT YEAR IT KEEP ME POSTED
OKAY. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BEFORE AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
HAVE SOME SENSE OF THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS- YOU KNOW FOR.
PROGRAMS WHEN WE ACTUALLY DON'T
RIGHT NOW AND- I'M A BELIEVER
THAT. SOME OF THESE TAX
EXPENDITURES WERE GONNA LOOK AT
AND SAY OH MY GOD THAT IS A
GREAT. USE OF CALIFORNIA FUNDS
LET'S DOUBLE DOWN ON THAT AND
MAYBE SOME OTHERS WE REALIZE
THAT. NOT GET OUR MONEY BACK
FOR THAT. CAN I JUST I'M ASK A
QUESTION THE- SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION AND MADE THE POINT
THAT THEY WERE SUBJECTIVE
EVALUATION METRICS WHICH-
FRANKLY KNOWING YOU FIND SO
MUCH HARD TO BELIEVE CAN YOU
JUST GIVE US KIND OF THE ONE
MINUTE. VERSION OF HOW THAT
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS. THE
BENEFIT SIDE. IT'S SIDE IS
GOING TO BE BY ITS NATURE.
DIFFICULT IF IT WERE EASY WE
COULD ASK THE AUDITOR TO DO IT-
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU WOULD SAY.
WE HAVE A PRTICULAR TAX BREAK
THIS IS WHAT IT COSTS THAT'S
THE PART WE NOW. THE QUESTION
WILL BE A FOR EXAMPLE IS
COMPARABLE TO OTHER STATES IF
IT'S LOWER. WE'LL FIND THAT N
AND WE MIGHT THEN WORRIED THAT
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE USINESS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A SIDE
TAX BREAK IF IT'S MUCH HIGHER
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES. THEN
WE SHOULD. TAKE A LOOK FOR
EXAMPLE AT THE CORPORATIONS
THAT WOULD- BENEFIT FROM THIS
TAX BREAK TO THEY LOCATE IN OUR
STATE OR DO THEY GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE. THAT'S WHAT WE WILL TRY
THAT'S WHAT WILL BE DONE TO
THAT EXTENT- AGAIN THE
INFORMATION'S GOING TO
PRESENTED TO US. SIX MONTHS
AFTER THAT WILL HAVE A HEARING
AND IT'LL BE UP TO US WHETHER
OR NOT WE WANT TO PURSUE THOSE
THERE WILL BE NO RECOMMENDATION
THEY'LL SIMPLY PRESENT THE
FACTS AS THEY SEE THEM. AND
THAT'LL BE AT. AND WILL WE TAKE
THINGS LIKE THAT DIRECT AND
INDIRECT JOB GROWTH INTO
ACCOUNT AND WILL THEY BE
CREATING SOME SORT OF A MODEL
FOR ESTIMATING THE ECONOMIC.
IT'S AN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
GENERATED BY THESE.
EXPENDITURES ARE TAX
INVESTMENTS AS YOU MIGHT WANT
TO YES IT SHOULD BE DIRECT. WE
HAVE THESE CORPORATIONS COMMAND
AN INDIRECT BECAUSE WE IF WE
DON'T GET THOSE CORPORATIONS
COMMAND WHAT ELSE ARE WE
MISSING SO YES YOU WOULD HAVE
THAT AS WELL. YEAH AND I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AND WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION- AS IN SUPPORT.
AND SEEING THAT DR BURKE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I ASKED FOR
A VOTE. BUT THAT IS HIGHLY
KALRA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
RIGHT. BURKE- A WIN. WINDLE
GRAY GRANO LOADING GRAYSON
GRAYSON I. LIVING LEVINE AYE
MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING MULLIN
WELL AND I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS- QUIRK ALL RIGHT
BURKE I RIVAS RIVAS I SAY R. TO
NOW SAY I DON'T KNOW. OF THE
VERY SEVENTY TWO THE BILL HAS
PASSED THAT THOSE OUT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE WOULD
YOU LIKE. TO PROTECT YOUR BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT TO AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE AS NOTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS AN
AUTHORS AMENDMENT MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERS AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WILL ESTABLISH THE GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION HEALING AND RECOVERY
ACT AND IMPOSE AN EXCISE TAX
UPON LICENSED FIREARMS DEALERS
AT A RATE OF TEN PERCENT. FOR
THE SALE OF HANDGUNS AND 11%
FOR THE SALE OF LONG GUNS AND
AMMUNITION TO CREATE A
CONSISTENT FUNDING MECHANISM
TOWARDS THE COST EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM KNOWN AS CAL THAT
MEMBERS ACCORDING TO THE GUN
VIOLENCE ARCHIVE IN THE FIRST
FOUR MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN KILLED DUE
TO GUN VIOLENCE IN JUST THE
MONTH OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SIXTY SIX AMERICANS WERE
KILLED BY GUN VIOLENCE
INCLUDING. EIGHT AT A SMALL
BUSINESS IN GEORGIA TEN AT A
GROCERY STORE IN COLORADO AND
FOR CALIFORNIANS KILLED ON
MARCH THIRTY FIRST AT AN OFFICE
COMPLEX IN ORANGE MEMBERS THESE
ARE NOT STATISTICS THEY ARE
HUMAN LIVES. GUN SALES IN
INCIDENTS OF GUN VIOLENCE HAVE
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY. SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TWENTY TWENTY
SAUDI 46% INCREASE IN GUN
HOMICIDES AND JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WAS THE DEADLIEST
MONTH FOR GUN HOMICIDES SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. THE CAL THE
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY BASED
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
IN THE STATE COMMUNITIES WHICH
RECEIVED CALVET FUNDING DURING
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CYCLE. SOFT
HOMICIDES DECREASED BY THREE
TIMES MORE THAN THOSE THAT DID
NOT RECEIVE CALVET SUPPORT. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THESE PROGRAMS
HELP CALIFORNIA REDUCE GUN
HOMICIDE AMONG THE HIGH RISK
AGE GROUP OF FIFTY NINE FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD. TO
THE LOWEST RATE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THESE PROGRAMS WORK.
GUN VIOLENCE WILL NOT END ON
ITS OWN. WE MUST TAKE
RESPONSIBLE ACTION TO END THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT IS
GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE. AND
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY AND WE SEE
MORE AND MORE INCIDENTS OF GUN
VIOLENCE WE MUST BE REMINDED
THAT WE ARE NEITHER HELPLESS.
NOR HOPELESS TO END THIS
CEASELESS BLOODSHED. AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE WILL PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THE CALVET PROGRAM. NEEDED TO
MAKE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL REDUCE GUN RELATED
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINE FOR OUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU DON'T LIVE NEAR OPEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
MY NAME IS GABRIEL GARCIA AND I
AM REPRESENTING YOU TO LIVE- WE
ARE NEED BASED ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING BOUNCE PREVENTION
INTERVENTION AND HEALING
SERVICES IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
WE CONNECTS WITH ALMOST EVERY
FAMILY OAKLAND WHO LOSES A
LOVED ONE HOMICIDE WE PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO GUNSHOT
VICTIMS FOR HOSPITAL BEDSIDE
AND WE WORK WITH YOU OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS AND THOSE COMING OUT OF
JUVENILE DETENTION PUT THEM ON
A TRACK TO SUCCESS. WE'RE ABLE
TO DO THIS WORK BECAUSE WE
RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM ME
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM. THE INVESTMENT
WE TALK ON HOW MUCH I OKAY. I
YOU BY ALMOST 50% AND THE
DECADE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER WE HAVE LOST MUCH OF
THAT PROGRESS IN THE LAST YEAR.
BY THE END OF MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OAKLAND HAD RECORDED
H. THREE HUNDRED AND 14%
INCREASE IN HOMICIDES. COMPARED
TO THE SAME TIME LAST YEAR. ON
AVERAGE WE EXPERIENCE THE
EQUIVALENT OF A MASS SHOOTING
EVERY TWO WEEKS. AND LATELY WE
HAVE BEEN SEEING THE EQUIVALENT
IN JUST ONE WEEKEND. BUT AS A
MEMBER LEVINE HAS BY WE KNOW
THAT THESE PROGRAMS WORK. STUDY
AFTER STUDY HAS BEEN CONDUCTED
ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BODY OF
RESEARCH OVERWHELMINGLY
CONFIRMS THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ARE NOT ONLY LIFESAVING. BUT
THEY ARE COST EFFECTIVE. EVERY
TIME ONE OF MY COWORKERS
IMMEDIATE CONFLICT THAT WOULD
LIKELY TO RESULT IN GUN
VIOLENCE WE SEE COST SAVINGS
ACROSS MEDICAL BILLS FUNERAL
COSTS AND CRIMINOLOGISTS
RESOURCES THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
USED. FOR CARBURETION AND COURT
PROCEEDINGS. ALL OF THE HUMAN
AND FINANCIAL COSTS ARE AVOIDED
ONLY A POWER BALLAD PREVENTION
PROFESSIONALS ROOTED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO KEEP THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS SAFE. I WE ARE
DOES NOT RESOURCE TO MEET THE
NEEDS PRESENTED BY THIS
HISTORIC RISING VIOLENCE. EVERY
YEAR PROGRAMS COME TO THE STATE
CAPITOL ASKING FOR INVESTMENT
IN TOWN THAT AND EVERY YEAR WE
SEE THE LOCAL INVESTMENTS JUST
NOT MEET THE NEEDS. AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE WOULD BE A MUCH
NEEDED STEP TO ENSURE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS LIKE OURS HAVE A
STEADY STREAM OF INVESTMENT.
SUBSIDIES LIKE OAKLAND WHO ARE
MOST HEAVILY IMPACTED BY GUN
VIOLENCE. CAN GET THESE
LIFESAVING RESOURCES FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY PRESSURE
AKA AND- THANK YOU- AND WE HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL WITNESS IN
SUPPORT I REMEMBER IT'S TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. HELLO AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL PALATO I'M NOT
SURE IF THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
ON DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE
PART OF EVERYTOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY. IT DOESN'T ACTIVE
VOLUNTEER SURVIVORS. AARON
CALIFORNIA. AMOUNTS OF HAS
ENORMOUSLY HARMFUL IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COMMUNITIES
AND TAXPAYERS. MAKING A MODEST
AND REASONABLE EXCISE TAX ON
THE FIRE MINISTRY TO FUND
PROGRAMS THAT YOU CAN MITIGATE
THE HARMS TOO OFTEN CAUSED BY
FIREARMS. IF THE NECESSARY STEP
IN ADDRESSING THE PERSONAL THE
FINAL AND FINANCIAL COSTS THE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO EXTORT IN THE CURRENT GUN
VIOLENCE CRISIS. COMPOUNDS
REMAIN THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH INJURY AND TRAUMA FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND ESPECIALLY
YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA. UNACCEPTABLE
MEANWHILE THE CAL THE GRANT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN ABOUT TWO CLICK ON
THE VIOLENCE AND PREVENTING
SHOOTINGS BEFORE THEY OCCUR.
THE PROGRAM STAINED MEANINGFUL
INVESTMENT TO CONTINUE THEIR
LIFE SAVING MARC AND WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE AND ONE IMPORTANT AVENUE.
TO PROVIDE THE. MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MONTEREY WOULD YOU PUT OPEN FOR
DISH NO WITNESSES OF. PLEASE
YOUR NAME A PHILLY. AMPAS ONLY.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE PESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'RE LIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S NICOLE
KIANA ON BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN
FOR GUN SAFETY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF THE GIFFORDS LAW CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GEMINI IT'S W. CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CAROL ROGERS I'M A
GUN VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
VOLUNTEER WITH THE EVERYTOWN
SURVIVOR NETWORK CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWELVE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS RACHEL MURRAY I AM A
GUN VIOLENCE SURVIVORS ARE
INVOLVED HERE WITH EVERYTOWN
SURVIVOR NETWORK CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
OUR MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES A
SUPPORT IN THE VIDEO TESTIMONY
ROOM NONE SO WE HAVE ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE
MODERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR A WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU BOTH
LINES ARE OPEN THANK YOU. I'M
SURE. YOUR MANAGER THIS IS AN
MEMBERS THIS IS ROY GRIFFIN
FROM THE AFTER CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION OUR
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS ROUTE
CALIFORNIA AMERITAS ARE STRONG
OPPOSITION SYMBOL TWELVE TWENTY
THREE THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE SEEN THIS
LEGISLATION THIS BILL AS
PREVIOUSLY REDUCING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN SESSIONS A. B.
EIGHTEEN AND THERE WERE OTHER
EFFORTS ON THE SAME FRONT. THE
AUTHORS STATED THE ANNUAL COST
ESTIMATES FROM GUN VIOLENCE
UNITED STATES AT OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE BILLION
EACH YEAR THESE COSTS ARE
CAUSED BY CRIMINALS NOT THE
INDIVIDUALS YOU SEEK TO TAX WE
STAND WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA BUT THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
SCHOOLS FIRST THE TAXING LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS FOR THE
ACTIONS OF LESSEN THE FRACTION
OF THE CRIMINALS. WHO BY THEIR
VERY NATURE ARE NOT LAW ABIDING
GUN OWNERS AND ACCOUNT FOR LESS
THAN A FRACTION OF EACH PERSON
OF THE POPULATION CRIMINALS
WILL NOT BE PAYING TAXES ON
FIREARMS THEY STEAL EACH YEAR
FIREARMS AMMUNITION ALREADY OUR
AMMUNITION SALES ALREADY BRING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO THE
TAXES. INTO CALIFORNIA STATE
BUDGET. COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
THERE ARE. WILL READ- TEN.
SALES TAX ALONG. ADDITIONAL
DAMAGE OF FORTY DOLLAR EACH
YEAR IS MADE IN THE- FOR
CONSERVE. EDUCATION EFFORTS
THROUGHOUT. CALIFORNIA FROM 11%
EXCISE TAX IMPOSED ON HE STILL
SPORTING ARMS. AND AMMUNITION
THE PITTMAN ROBERTSON ACT. THE
PROPOSED TAX WHICH CLEARLY.
IMPEDES THE CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED ACTIVITY RAISES
SERIOUS LEGAL QUESTIONS AS TO
WHETHER FUNDS RATE IN THIS
MANNER CAN BE SPENT ON THIS
KIND OF POLICY. CASE LAW MAKES
IT CLEAR. THAT THEY MAY NOT
IMPOSE A CHARGE FOR ENJOYMENT
OF A RIGHT GRANTED BY THE
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION AND A
PERSON CANNOT BE COMPELLED TO
PURCHASE THROUGH TAX OR FEE A
PRIVILEGE FREELY GRANTED BY THE
CONSTITUTION IT'S COVERED IN.
DOG. PUSHES PENNSYLVANIA.
TRANSACTION HAS. RELEASED DOWN
IN JURISDICTIONS AMERIPRISE TAX
INSTANCE TO. SHELTERS FOR
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WAS RECENTLY STRUCK DOWN ON
SIMILAR GROUNDS IN THAT CASE
THE COURT POINTED OUT THAT THE
STATUTE. CANNOT VIOLATE THE
CONSTITUTION NO MATTER HOW
DESIRABLE OR BENEFICIAL. THE
LEGISLATION IN NINETEEN. THANK
YOU BYE THANK YOU- WE- UNDER
THE LAW TO IMPOSE TIERED IN
CONNECTION WITH AN EXERCISE OF
A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THESE
FEES ARE DESIGNED TO RECRUIT
COST ONLY CAN RECOUP COSTS THAT
FOR. INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS BEING
SUBJECTED TO WE STRONGLY
STANDING VERY STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS MATTER ENTER HERE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COUNCIL OF THE OF THE BORDER
THAT WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ANY
FURTHER CLARIFICATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE OPEN THE
LINE FOR ANY. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU DON'T NUMBERS. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS APPARATUS
REPRESENTING GOVERNMENTS
CALIFORNIA WE POSES LESS
LEGISLATION FROM A FOUNDATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE IN THAT TAXIS IN
THE NUMERATOR RIGHT IS NOT ONLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT IS
STRONGLY PREJUDICIAL WHY WOULD
ANYONE WANT TO PENALIZE LAW
ABIDING OR ENGAGING IN A
PERFECTLY LEGAL FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION OF THE PERFECTLY
LEGAL PRODUCT CONVERSELY IF
YOU'RE PROPOSAL SOUGHT TO LEVY
A SPECIAL TAX ON SOMEONE WHO
HAD COMMITTED A CRIME WHILE
USING A FARM STAND AT LEAST
THERE'S A NEXUS TO THE PROBLEM
YOU IN THE SALT PENALIZING THE
LAW BY THE- FOR THE MISDEEDS OF
THE UNLAWFUL SEEMS MISDIRECTED
ATTEMPT UNITIVE. AND THE MEN
AMENDMENTS THAT DRAMATICALLY
EXPAND THE INITIAL TAX OF
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
REQUIREMENTS TWO PERCENTAGE OF
THE SALES TAX FOR BOTH FARMS
AND AMMUNITION IT SEEMS TO BE
MORE RETALIATORY IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES THE REYES
AND EXPEND RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
VIOLENCE OF ANY KIND- A GUN
RELATED OR OTHERWISE SHOULDN'T
THAT BE A COST BORNE BY THE
WHOLE OF CALIFORNIA'S TAXPAYERS
RATHER THAN SINGLING OUT THOSE
WHO CHOOSE TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM AFTER ALL OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF FIREARMS. USED IN
CRIMES ARE EITHER STOLEN OR
SECURED ON THE BLACK MARKET BY
THIEVES IN FACT ACCORDING TO
THE TWELVE TWENTY NINETEEN U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON THE
SOURCE OF USE OF FIREARMS
INVOLVED IN CRIMES ONLY ONE
POINT 3% OBTAINED THE GUN FROM
A RETAIL SOURCE MADAM CHAIR
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT IF
THIS BILL IS PASSED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW THAT THERE WILL BE A
LAWSUIT TO CHALLENGE IT. AND
THE MATTER OF FACT BECAUSE THAT
LOSS WILL BE THE CHALLENGE ALL
EXCISE TAXES AND SALES TAXES
RELATED TO FIREARMS WE DON'T-
TAX CHURCHES WE DON'T TAX ME
SPEECH WILLIAM ATTACHED
NEWSPAPERS ONE PURCHASED THE-
AT A NEWSPAPER BOX YOU CANNOT
TAX- A PERSON WHO'S EXERCISING
THEIR FUNDAMENTAL SACRAMENTO
RIGHT FOR THESE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU A
MODERATOR YOU PLEASE A THE LINE
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
ALL. EMPLOYEES JUST NAME OF
PHILLY. AND PUT PLEASE. THANK
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IT UP AS
OF A BALL TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PER ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'RE DELIGHTED EIGHT
NINE THESE PLAID. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RON LANDER
AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. STE C. R. PA
CHAPTER ON BEHALF OF OUR
HUNDRED SIXTY MEMBERS AND
FAMILIES WE OPPOSE. STRONGLY
THIS BILL THANK. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR KATHY LYNCH REPRESENTING
OUTDOOR SPORTS AND COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY THE FIGHT
CLUB IN OUR NATIONAL IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL AS MEANWHILE
CORPORATION AND DOING
ENTERPRISES TO PROVIDE.
AMMUNITION AND FIREARMS TO
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECURITY.
STE THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHREDDED DON
SLIMES- IN LAKE COUNTY I AM A
MEMBER OF STE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL
DEFENSIVE PISTOL ASSOCIATION
AND I AM ACTIVE IN TWO GUN
CLUBS IN LAKE AND MENDOCINO
COUNTY WITH OVER TWO THOUSAND
MEMBERS WHO ARE HONEST- BONTA
FORSMAN SUPPORTING. PEOPLE WE
ARE STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION TO
AN ADDITIONAL TAX ON A BASIC
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SIR
MY NAME IS MICHAEL FINLEY WITH
THE NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION WERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS A THANK YOU MY NAME
IS STEVE RODDA GERMAN AMANDA
LIKE CINEMA COUNTY CHAPTER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. AN NRA LIFE MEMBER
AND A US NAVY VETERAN STRONGLY
URGING OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BYE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GLAD. HI MY JAMES
WESTFALL- FROM FREMONT
CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY CAMP OWNERS
CHAPTER OF SHE R. P. H. AND R.
A AND ALSO A CALIFORNIA GUN
OWNERS ASSOCIATION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MARK SMITH
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN WE'VE HAD.
THANK YOU CARLENE ELLIS AND I'M
A COMPETITION SHOOTER WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL THE BALLOT TO
FULFILL CREATION I BELONG TO
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION THEM SACRAMENTO
DEFENSIVE THIS IS SHOOTERS AND
I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AN
ADDITIONAL TAX ON FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY THREE
PRESS OR AT. BERMAN SERVICE
MCMAHON ON THE CHAIR OF THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. AND AN OLD MEMBER
AND TRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
TONY WERE ABOLISHED FROM
CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
JERRY BROWN AND- THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND OWNER
OF FAMILY THE SON CCW AND
FIREARMS TRAINING STRONGLY
OPPOSING THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MY NAME IS
DARREN BUT WELL I MADE MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIGHT WELL
FIRST NOT THE CASE AS WELL AS
GRAND- ORGANIZATION BACK ON
OWNER AND I'M STRONG. THANK YOU.
SHE KEEPS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FOURTEEN. PLAYS GO AHEAD. YES
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE THE
RECORD REID WITH THE MASS RIFLE.
HERE IN STRONG ABA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS KATHY
GRAHAM I AM ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
AND- I'M ALSO AN NRA MEMBER
VALID HUNTER. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS. TAX IT'S UNFAIR TO THE
STATE MEDICAL PEOPLE THAT THANK
YOU NAME POSITION AND THANK YOU
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
PLEASE THANK YOU MODERATOR HOW
MANY MORE DO WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. I HAVE SIX MORE IN Q.
IT'S DO IT ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KELLY HOW CAN BUT THE
CONVENTIONAL FORTUNE FOUNDATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JOSE LOPEZ OFFERS I'M A
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA LIFELINE
BECAUSE SHE SHOULD SEND AYE
OPPOSED AB ONE TWO THREE SIX
THANK YOU STE STE THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SCOTT I'M CALLING
DOCTOR COUNTY INMATES. OPPOSE
A. TWELVE TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM SURE MY
NEIGHBORS GO GAINES SPEAKING
TODAY ABOUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FOR CONSERVATION THE
WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEER ASSOCIATION AND
TEN OTHER CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS AND STRONG
OPPOSITION AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SCOTT KAUFMAN HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVENTY TWO YES. YES WHAT TRIED
LOADING THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
FOR ONCE BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
CALLS COMING IN. SECOND
AMENDMENT OKAY SECOND NOW
MAINTAINED I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT. AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
WITH ANY OTHER WITH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
VIDEO TESTIMONY ROOM. I'M
ASSUMING L. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION HEARING ROOM
NONE. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M SURE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
WITH THAT MISS I WHEN YOU CALL
THE ROLL- I WOULD HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION
THE BILL. AND WE HAVE A SECOND.
WITH THAT IT'S CALLED. THE
MOTION HAS DEEP PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE NINE
BURKE I PLAN. WELL YOU KNOW J.
GREEN L. GRAY. LIVING FIVE
MILLION I MAYES MAYES NOW
MULLIN MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
YOUR NORRIS I QUIRK MY- CORRECT
I. RIVAS RIVAS I SAY ART UP NOW
CYRANO. HAPPY BIRTHDAY. SIX
ONE. YOUR BILL IS OUT WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO ADD ON'S
EVERYONE ELSE I. WE HAVE A BILL
ON CALL IT'S FILE ITEM. TWO AB
SIXTY FIVE. AB SIXTY FIVE
MISSILE AND YOU CALL THE ROLL.
WELL IN. WELL CHANGE YOUR TO
GRAY. AB SIXTY FIVE HELLO.
LOWVILLE. UNIVERSAL INCOME.
IT'S THE BILL HAS PASSED NOW.
ALL RIGHT WELL DONE OR NOT AND
THE VICE TO RELATED. NO WHEN
NOT VOTING TO KNOW. ALL RIGHT
THEN MISTER BOLAN. MAKE SURE
YOU'RE ON. WE ARE MAKE SURE YOU
NEED TO VOTE ON EVERYTHING IS
HE YEAH SO WE'LL START WITH
FILE I DON'T TO I JUST HAVE ON
HIM ON IT AB AT MISPERTON SPELL.
MONOZYGOTIC THANK YOU WE ARE.
THAT WITH THAT. WE ARE PREPARED
TO ADJOURN CORRECT WITH
THAILAND YEAH.